Auf Wiedersehen!
Wunderschönen guten Abend, ihr hört Fritz. Hier ist das Chaos Radio, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat der Blumen. Weitestgehend mit dem Chaos Computer Club, der hier auch reichhaltig erschienen ist und zwar in Form von Tobias Thorsten und Krügs.
Guten Abend.
Guten Tag.
Ja, das Mikrofon ist zu niedrig für dich, ne?
Dein ist zu groß.
Ja, vielleicht tauscht ihr einfach die Plätze. Habt ihr da auch schon mal nachgedacht? Einfach so jetzt als Dingsbums. Chaos Radio Nummer 83 haben wir's. Ich kenne mich nicht aus, darum sagt ihr doch, worum es geht, bitte.
Abenteuer, Letzte Meile. Ja, das geht um alles, was man irgendwie so...
Um dieses Stück Kupferkabel oder manchmal auch Glasfaserkabel von der Vermittlungsstelle zu euch nach Hause und was damit so alles schiefgeht, was die Telekom euch als toll und multimedial verkaufen will und in Wirklichkeit... Ja, wir wollen wissen, was da in Wirklichkeit bei rauskommt und ob das auch alles immer so klappt, wie es in den Werbeprospekten beworben wird.
Ja, das ist das Thema im Chaos Radio 83, aber vorher wollte Krügs noch ein wenig Camps-Spam machen.
Ja, genau, der Chaos Computer Club veranstaltet im August wieder das Chaos Communication Camp in der Nähe von Berlin und das fand vor vier Jahren schon mal statt. Und jetzt gibt es sozusagen die Fortsetzung. Wir verlegen also das Hacken raus auf die Wiese, an den See. Und es wird wieder Internet-Satz geben, vorauslich 150 MBit, wenn alles gut geht. Natürlich auch Waveline, sodass man mit Notebook im Zelt oder am See hacken kann. Es wird ein prall gefülltes Workshop-Porteur und Vortragsprogramm geben von Hackern aus der ganzen Welt über alle möglichen Themen, die so den Datenreisenden interessieren. Es gibt natürlich auch eine Website dazu, warum auch nicht, unter www.ccc.de. Da kann man sich das alles erklicken. Man kann sogar an der Gestaltung der Website mitwirken. Da gibt es einen Wiki, da kann man selber Texte reinschreiben. Wiki, Wiki, Pateng.
Wiki, Pateng? Pateng. Was ist nicht Hekki Patang?
Pateng. Also, Vormerken, Urlaub nehmen, Chaos Communication Camp vom 7. bis zum 10. August an Alt Landsberg vor den Turm Berlins.
Wie gehabt, also da wo es auch vor vier Jahren war auf dem Turm Berlins.
Genau, wieder an Alt Landsberg auf dem Reiterhof.
Ach, das ist schon wieder so Jamaikaner, also armdicke Leitungen.
Armdicke, ja 155 Mbit sind jetzt.
Ich hab eben nicht zugehört.
Du hast wieder nicht zugehört, natürlich.
Na, weil Tobias hatte Probleme.
Ja, ja.
Ne, ne, ne.
Mit Tobias gibt es doch immer Probleme. Diesmal aber mit Drahtlos, oder?
Natürlich, Wavelang gibt es auch. Von siebten bis zum zehnten August in Landsberg.
Ah ja, willkommen im Chaosradio 83 hier.
Danke schön.
Abenteuer, Letzte Meile ist das Thema hier im Chaosradio. Letzte Meile ist der Teil vom Telefon, den die Telekom nicht verkauft hat, also damit meiste Geld verdient oder so ähnlich. So ungefähr. So ungefähr. Wie ist denn mit euren Anschlüssen? Alles so okay soweit? Ich kann dir nicht klagen, DSL funktioniert jeden zweiten Tag nicht, also nichts besonderes.
Ich hab kein Telekom mehr.
Ich hab jetzt auch Telekom, aber das funktioniert erstaunlicherweise.
Wie du hast kein Telekom mehr gekriegt?
Na ich hab wahrscheinlich alles, was mit Telekom zu tun hat, einfach mal abgeschafft und bin auf alternative Anbieter umgestiegen.
Welche? Also DSL, QSC wahrscheinlich, ne?
Genau, QSC, zwei Leitungen halt und Telefon hat man sowieso nur noch ein Mobiltelefon. Ich meine, was soll das mit einem Festabschluss?
Ich hab Festnetz.
Ist ja schon günstiger, wenn man mit einem Festnetz Mutti in...
Ich ruf meine Mutti nicht an.
Ich hab keine Eltern.
Ja, ich hatte schlechte Erfahrungen, so mit hohen Rechnungen und so ein Kram.
Das hatte ich ja noch nie, das Problem hohe Rechnungen. Also jetzt nicht höher als die, die ich selbst... Also das konnte ich schon immer nachvollziehen.
Sie wurden schon produziert, aber sie wurden... Also es ging konkret darum, dass es damals diese ISDN Flatrate gab. Sie die dann umgestellt haben auf Surftime 90, also Minutengenauer, irgendwie Abrechnung. Und das haben sie halt über die T-Online-Mail-Adresse mitgeteilt. Die hab ich natürlich nie benutzt, weil sowieso kein Windows und nicht die T-Online Zugangssoftware. Und dann war halt die Rechnung mit den 1400 DM irgendwann auf dem Tisch.
Du willst sagen, wenn ich T-Online benutze und da die Flatrate nehme, da hab ich auch eine Mail-Adresse, wo die mir die Sachen hinschicken?
Ja, sicher.
Da hast du ja auch einen privaten Web-Space da drin, den du nutzen darfst.
Ja, und deine Adresse finden alle raus, wenn sie, was? HOMETEONLINE und so weiter, Punkt Impressum eingeben. Zumindest war das früher immer so. Stand dann immer Anschrift, Telefonnummer von allen. Nee, du hast automatisch eine Adresse. Und wenn du, also auch sehr schön, die haben zuletzt haben sie Post geschickt, die haben noch diesen, was man überall konnte, also eine beliebige Absender-E-Mail-Adresse eintragen. Wenn du dich denn dann auf dem Server identifiziert hast, auf dem SMTP, das ging bei denen ja eine Zeit lang nicht, dann haben sie ihren SMTP Relay-Server geschaltet, was alles ganz toll funktioniert hat. Und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, wenn sie jetzt weiter diesen Relay-Server benutzen wollen, dann zahlen sie bitte drei Euro im Monat.
Genau, das ist jetzt Kohle.
Die haben doch einen Arsch auf, oder Entschuldigung, einen Rad ab. Ich meine, da kriegst du also, naja.
Ja, ich hab mich gerade wieder eine Woche mit der Telekom geprügelt. Ich hab irgendwie eine Nummer, eine zusätzliche MSN, sozusagen, sollte von einem anderen ISDN-Anschluss auf meinen ISDN-Anschluss transferiert werden. Und ich hab ganz brav einen Auftrag aufgegeben und hab auch eine Auftragsbestätigung erhalten, wo halt drin steht, dann und dann wird das geschaltet. Ist natürlich nichts passiert. Und dann hab ich bei der Störungsstelle angerufen, hab gefragt, was los ist. Also nachdem ich noch mal irgendwie beim Vertrieb angerufen habe und die mir gesagt haben, ne ne, der Auftrag ist durchgegangen und alles ist gut. Und wenn es nicht geht, dann müssen sie sich an die Störungsstelle wenden, hab ich dann gemacht. Und die haben mir so eine knappe Woche lang jeden Tag erzählt, irgendwie so, ja, wir geben es noch mal ein. Und am nächsten Tag haben sie mir dann immer erzählt, ja, das ist hier als erledigt gekennzeichnet worden, das müsste jetzt funktionieren. Ich hab immer gesagt, nö, das funktioniert aber nicht. Und dann waren so zwischendurch so tolle Sachen wie, dass ich halt schon fast eine Woche immer mit denen gesprochen hatte und mir dann plötzlich erzählt wurde bei der Störungsstelle, ja, da müssen Sie sich noch gedulden, Sie haben die Störung ja gerade erst um 13.40 Uhr gemeldet. Und ich so, ja, das tue ich aber irgendwie seit letzte Woche. Nee, tun Sie nicht. Ich tue das seit letzte Woche, nee, tun Sie nicht. Doch tue ich, kann ich mal bitte Ihren Teamleiter sprechen? Nö, können Sie nicht, klick. So, und dann irgendwie noch mal angerufen und...
Hast du schon mal versucht, als vielleicht irgendjemand schon mal versucht, sich wirklich zu beschweren zu sagen, der Herr Schneide-Reit hat mich gerade schlecht behandelt?
Das Problem ist, wo willst du dich beschweren?
Ja, Pressestelle, Bildzeitung, keine Ahnung, also ja, beim Teamleiter.
Ja, und dann irgendwie, als die Woche fast voll war und ich mal wieder angerufen habe, haben sie mir dann erzählt, ja, das kann auch gar nicht, wir können das gar nicht schalten. Und es liegt gar kein Auftrag vor, dann müssen sie bitte beim Vertrieb wieder anrufen. Nach einer Woche, ja. So, und da ist mir dann der Kragen, vor allen Dingen, das Parfide ist ja, dass man dann immer hin und her geschickt wird. Und dann habe ich natürlich beim Vertrieb angerufen, da wurde mir gesagt, nee, nee, also da hat eigentlich die Störungsstelle total einen Blödsinn erzählt, der Auftrag ist durchgegangen. So rufen sie bitte wieder beim Service an. Und dann, sie haben es dann irgendwann hingekriegt, als ich dann gesagt habe, sie mögen doch mal bitte irgendwie miteinander sprechen, statt mich immer von A nach B zu schicken. Aber es hat halt, wie gesagt, im Großen und Ganzen eine Woche gedauert. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie das so im Großberliner Durchschnitt liegt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich sehe gerade, der Einbeiniger hat hier gerade, der sitzt ja immer an der Hotline, der hat gerade eine Nachricht auf den Bildschirm hier geschrieben, bei der Telekom immer den vollen Namen vor dem Gespräch geben lassen. Und dann sind die, Basti, automatisch freundlicher. Du kannst im Zweifel zwar einen ankanken hier, das ist richtig allerdings. So, so weit Tobias und Kroeks Thorsten, was macht denn dein Telefon so, wie geht es dem denn?
Das funktioniert ganz gut, also ich kann im Moment noch nicht klagen, aber ich bin ja auch gerade erst umgezogen und habe diesen Anschluss.
Sonst lasst uns doch mal die Hörer fragen, ob es eigentlich, also ich meine, eine Woche fand ich schon ziemlich dreist irgendwie, aber gab es denn da eigentlich?
Könnt ihr da drüber geneigte Hörende? Also wer hat denn schon länger als eine Woche auf eine wie auch immer geartete, zumindest ehrliche Auskunft der Deutschen Telekom gewartet?
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch und sollt das auch all die anderen schönen Geschichten hier abgeben, die es da sonst noch so zu erzählen gibt, zum Beispiel, dass man falsche rebührenpflichtige Nummern angesagt kriegt, wie das mir der einst passierte. Tobias hat hier eben erzählt, dass er eine Woche lang in der Warteschleife der Deutschen Telekom verbracht hat. Ohne, dass das auch nur irgendein Nutzen für ihn gehabt hätte. Die Frage war, könnt ihr da eigentlich drüber geneigt hören? Falls ihr könnt, 0331 70 97 110. Falls ihr noch haarsträubendere Geschichten über, oder mit oder um die Deutsche Telekom zu erzählen wisst, dann ist auch die Fritzwortline 0331 70 97 110 die Nummer eurer Wahl. Und angerufen, da hat jetzt der Marc.
Hallo Marc.
Hallo.
Du kannst drüber über die eine Woche?
Ja locker. Locker.
Es war allerdings nicht so ärgerlich, weil ich eigentlich meinen normalen Telefonbetrieb dadurch nicht sonderlich gestört gesehen habe. Es hat aber, in einer Größenordnung, mindestens ein halbes Jahr gedauert, bevor das funktionierte.
Und worum ging es da?
Es hatte einen ISDN-Komfortanschluss. Und in diesem ISDN-Komfortanschluss, das ist mittlerweile alles schon eine ganze Weile her, da gab es damals ganz neu diese Mailbox mit drinne. Die T-Net-Box. Faktisch bei der Telekom AG.
Genau, die T-Net-Box.
Die gibt es eigentlich noch?
Die wird jetzt super gepusht.
Ach echt?
In der Zwischenzeit habe ich kein ISDN mehr, aber damals hatte ich das, habe die T-Net-Box auch genutzt. Und jeden Monat wurde mir mit einer extremen Vehemenz diese wieder in Rechnung gestellt. Obwohl ich einen Komfortanschluss hatte. Nach dem ersten Anruf, oh ja, tut uns leid, ein Versehen, wenn wir ihn mit der nächsten Rechnung dann ausgleichen, dann ein Monat später, oh ja, tut uns leid, das muss wohl nicht durchgestellt worden sein. Und so ging das dann immer weiter. Ich hatte dann die netten Damen da schon ein paar Namen gekannt.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, was kostet dieses Ding?
Ich glaube, es waren irgendwie 6 Mark oder so.
Für ein bisschen Speicherplatz?
Ich glaube, 4 Mark oder mit Fax-Funktion dann irgendwie. Also ich glaube, es sind jetzt 2 Euro für die T-Net-Box, wenn man sie nicht im Komfortanschluss drin hat, und dann nochmal 2 Euro für die Fax-Funktion oder so was.
Jedenfalls ging die ganze Geschichte wirklich etwa über ein halbes Jahr. Kann sein, dass es auch ein bisschen länger war, bis mir dann irgendwann der Kragen geplatzt ist am Telefon. Und ich habe gesagt, es ist mir so über jetzt jeden Monat, wenn ich die Rechnung bekomme, da drüber zu gucken und zu sehen, ob das wieder mit in Rechnung gestellt war. Ich möchte jetzt was haben dafür. Und da haben die sich doch wirklich bereit erklärt, mir 500 Freieinheiten dafür zu geben. Das fand ich dann noch mal ganz nobel. Aber in allem war es natürlich ein untragbarer Zustand.
Bist du da irgendwie mit Waffen reinmarschiert? Oder warum haben die das gemacht?
Ich habe schon das gemacht, was hier der Einbeinige schon angemerkt hat. Richtig schön Namen aufschreiben und auch eine Notiz, wann man mit wem gesprochen hat, immer gleich auf die Telefonrechnung drauf. Die ersten zwei Monate hatte ich das natürlich noch nicht gemacht. Aber als man dann immer weiter die Geschichte vorbeten konnte, an dem und dem angerufen mit Herrn so und so und so gesprochen, dann wurde es den Leuten da selbst peinlich.
Huet, Marc, vielen Dank. Und einen schönen Abend noch. Wir haben noch einen. Markus, du willst uns die Party kaputt machen?
Mach mal.
Und zwar, als ich umgezwungen bin, habe ich einen ISDN-Korporationsschluss bei der Telekom beantragt, bei diesem Teleladen. Und hat so, glaube ich, drei Wochen gedauert, bis sie dann in meine Wohnung kamen. Da kamen zwei Leute. Und ja, muss ich sagen, die haben mir mitgeteilt, wo wir uns jetzt gelebt haben. Und dann hatten die satte zwei Stunden gebraucht. Und dann lief das sogar auf Anhieb.
Nicht schlecht, das war bei mir nicht so. Bei mir hat es schon beim Nachbarn geklingelt irgendwie am ersten Tag.
Ich muss sagen, ich hatte schon mal auch so ein Negativbeispiel. Ich habe mal bei einer Firma gearbeitet, im Internet. Und da kam einer und wollte die Standlatung anschließen, an Funkzeichen. Und wollte dann wissen, welche Nummer die Standlatung hätte. Anstatt sich auf seinem Auftrag, da hat er einfach so eine Ladung, hat er irgendwie so eine Nummer, so eine Identifikationsnummer. Und der wollte immer so eine Telefonnummer haben. Und da dachte ich zumindest, oh Gott, wenn so ein Typ so mit uns nach Hause kommt, der hat doch gar keine Peilung.
Du hast die Party ja jetzt nicht ganz kaputt gemacht, weil ich lese hier nur, dass bei dir alles geklappt hat, was du mit der Telekom zu tun hattest.
Im Privaten hatte ich immer Schwein garen. Ich hab auch von anderen gehört, da kommt so einer her. Und dann, naja, ich hatte das Glück, dass ich nicht mehr mit dem Support telefonieren muss. Und dann, dieser Mensch, da war einer, der war so ein Älterer. Ich glaube, der hat jetzt rausgerissen. Der hatte mit diesem Jungen wieder bei mir immer mitgeteilt, was er gerade machen sollte. Aber das Gute fand ich, da hat mich sogar vorher gefragt, auf welchen Anspruch ich was für Endgeräte machen will. Analog oder ob ich nochmal mit ISDN auf B-Kanal oder so was. Also der war irgendwie kundenorientiert, denke ich mal.
Das ist ohnehin ganz verblüffend. Also immer wenn man jemanden bei der Telekom an der Hotline dran hat, der oder die irgendwie älter klingt, die wissen in der Regel, was sie da tun. Das ist mir auch schon ein paar Mal aufgefallen.
Ja, das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Ich hab auch mit der Telekom manchmal so ein bisschen Zwiss gehabt, aber das hat mich dann dazu bewogen zu sagen, Mensch, das ist ja doch noch nicht ganz drauf, wo das Malz verloren werden kann, wie eine rosa-roten Dinosaurier. Aber es scheint doch manchmal, wenn ich überlege...
Wenn du das dreckige Grinsen in den Gesichtern der drei Jungs, die mir gegenüber sitzen, sehen könntest, dann wüsstest du, dass das nicht stimmt, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Also man muss sagen, es gibt da auch tatsächlich Leute, die wirklich Ahnung haben.
Ja, mit 55 gehört man nämlich noch lange nicht zum alten Eisen.
Ganz genau.
Alle Frührentner sofort an die Telekom-Hotline und die ganzen jungen Spunde raus, oder wie?
Ganz genau, da fängt das Leben erst an.
Gut gereffte Telekom-Techniker.
Ganz genau, so sieht es aus.
Ich bezahle aber Geld dafür.
Wenn ich Geld für irgendetwas bezahle, dann will ich nicht, dass das mit Glück zu tun hat, was da hinten rauskommt. Man möchte eigentlich das Wetten abschließen kann. Wie lange brauche ich jetzt, um bei der Telekom was zu erreichen?
Damit könnte man Geld machen.
Danke Markus einstweilen.
Tschüss.
Das Chaosradio hat herausgefunden, ältere Hotline-Mitarbeiter bei der Deutschen Telekom sind durchaus in der Lage, einem bei Problemen weiterzuhelfen, jüngeren nicht. Woher kommt das? Ich dachte, Alte können mit Technik nicht so gut umgehen.
Tja, woher kommt das? Also ich hab da mal mit einem Telekom-Mitarbeiter gesprochen und es gibt da wohl Probleme mit Schulungsmaßnahmen und so und das ist halt eine Tatsache, dass sie sich da einiges selber beibringen müssen. Also die kriegen keine Schulung, die kriegen irgendwie eine neue Hardware in die Hand gedrückt. Als DSL ganz neu war, gab es auch keine Schulung. Es gab Monate später, nachdem die dann erst mal davor standen und keine Ahnung hatten, Monate später gab es eine Schulung, wie man eine Netzwerkkarte einbaut und einen PC. Aber das war es halt auch. Anscheinend kein Geld da.
Verblüffend, das heißt jeder Depp darf da hingehen und kriegt dann da Arbeit? Okay, wir haben noch einen Anrufer mit einem Positivbeispiel, bevor wir also die Telekom total zerreißen.
Ja, das ist positiv und negativ. Negativ für das Telekom, positiv für mich.
Das macht die besser.
Also erstens mal krieg ich meine Rechnung für ein Festnetz. Die kriegt man über Telekom. Und wenn man jetzt für einen anderen Anbieter ist, die lass ich immer die Mahnung verstreichen. Und dann krieg ich den Mahnungskosten ein Euro drauf. Die Rechnung ist aber 33 Euro. Und die Rechnung, die ich mit dem 1 Euro Mahnungskosten kriege, die ist ja nur 28.
Immer? Ist das jedes Mal so? Jedes Mal so.
Das ist jedes Mal selbe. Es muss ja dämlich sein, die Rechnung gleich zu bezahlen.
Ja, wenn du lang genug wartest, dann kriegst du sogar noch was raus.
Ja, das muss eigentlich so sein, ja. Und noch ein anderes Beispiel, Internet. Da haben wir tatsächlich mal den Fehler gemacht und haben über Telekom gemacht. Aber da gab es nur Probleme im Netz, weil da wurden dann plötzlich irgendwelche Seiten zugemacht. Wenn ich irgendwo bei Talkline reingehen wollte oder so, dann kam hier irgendwo der Banner drüber von Telekom. Und irgendwas war das zu. Und da hab ich gesagt, das ist nicht so doof. Und bin dann halt zum anderen an Mittag gegangen. Und nur ging das in ganz Zeit lang hin und her, da hab ich immer die Rechnung gekriegt von der Telekom. Und da hab ich gesagt, ich bin überhaupt nicht bei euch. Was wird überhaupt von mir? Genau heute hab ich 12 Euro für Rechnungscheck gekriegt. Das geht überhaupt nicht.
Das ist nett.
Nur das Theater hat man natürlich, ne?
Vielen Dank Roland.
Das ist cool.
Jede Mahnung 5 Euro gespart.
Das sollte man mal ausprobieren.
6 Euro, da ist ja noch 1 Euro Mahnkosten dabei.
Na, die musst du ja wieder zahlen, oder? Warte mal, er meinte 33 Euro und die Rechnung nachher mit 1 Euro Mahnkosten sind 28 Euro.
Ja, mit nahen Kosten hat die Telekom sowieso ihre Probleme. Bei mir damals schwankte dann die Rechnung auch so um 100 Euro Beträge und sie konnten sich nicht darauf einigen, was denn nur der wirkliche Rechnungsbetrag wäre und welcher nicht und so. Also ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, dass man bei der Telekom bei falschen Rechnungen einfach auf gar keinen Fall zahlen sollte, weil das Geld sieht man nie wieder. Also wenn das einmal da verschwunden ist, dann sieht man das nicht wieder. Und wenn man es wieder sieht, dann meistens nur als Freiminuten auf der Telefonrechnung. Und man will nicht 560 Euro Freiminuten auf der Telekom rechnen.
Wenn Fritz in Neukölln, dann 100 2, 6.
Fritz Info.
Erstmals Wetter in der Nacht erwarten uns wenige Wolken bei Tiefstwerten zwischen 13 und 9 Grad. Morgen wirds heiter und trocken. Die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 22 und 26 Grad. Die Meldung jetzt mit Bastian Berner.
Die Bundesregierung will nun angeblich definitiv die letzte Stufe der Steuerreform vorziehen, das schreibt die Süddeutsche Zeitung. Die Reform soll schon im nächsten Jahr in Kraft treten. Durch sie sollen Bürgerunternehmen um insgesamt 18 Milliarden Euro entlastet werden. Im Streit um die 35-Stunden-Woche im Osten wird es morgen ein Spitzentreffen geben. IG-Metallchef Zwickl und Gesamtmetallchef Kanagisa wollen an einem geheimen Ort miteinander sprechen. Übermorgen sollen dann die offiziellen Verhandlungen weitergehen. In der liberianischen Hauptstadt Manrovia hat es eine schwere Explosion auf dem Gelände der US-Botschaft gegeben. Dort sind offenbar mehrere Granaten eingeschlagen. Auf dem Gelände haben tausende liberianische Bürgerkriegspflichtlinge Zuflucht gesucht. Über Tote und Verletzte weiß man noch nichts. Die Rauschgiftexperten der UNO haben die Partydroge Ecstasy zum Staatsfeind Nr. 1 erklärt. Es sei besorgniserregend, dass viele Menschen den Missbrauch synthetischer Drogen scheinbar tolerieren. Insgesamt gehe die Produktion von Drogen weltweit aber zurück. Unterverkehr auf Fritz, wir haben aktuell keine Meldungen für euch, deswegen gute Fahrt.
Rollschuhe sind schwer im Kommen.
Und was kommt?
Kommt bei uns.
Zum Ferienanfang.
Die Fritz Rollschuhdisco im Casino Berlin.
Mit kostenlosen Rollschuhverleih und eintrittfrei. Also rollt hin und kommt vorbei.
Die Radiofritzen am Nachmittag sind auch da.
Die Fritz Rollschuhdisco.
Zum Ferienanfang. Nächsten Mittwoch ab 14 Uhr im Casino Berlin.
Mühlenstraße 26, Berlin-Friedrichshain. Der Sommer auf Rollen.
Ein bisschen Musik und wir werden alle Nacht sein.
Hier ist es, Chaosradio 83, Abenteuer, Letzte Meile. Das ist unser Thema heute, die Letzte Meile, die Telekom von der Straße bis in eure Wohnungen legt. Im Studio Robert T. Online, Robert T. Online, Robert T. Online und ich bin Eni. Ja, ich bewerbe da ja gerade ganz tolle Sachen. Also mit WLAN ist ja irgendwie so der neueste Hype der deutschen T.
Ja, also die Telekom, ich hab neulich gerade gelesen, dass WLAN-Equipment Sales 120% up sind im letzten Jahr. Das stand irgendwie auf Slashdot oder so, glaub ich. Und ja, Thorsten, du hattest doch erzählt, die Telekom verkloppt jetzt irgendwie das ganze Equipment da für irgendwie wenig Geld und mit viel Werbeeinsatz, unter anderem von Eni. T.
ISDN, ich meine dieses T. SINOS 130 DSL. Ja, das ist jetzt irgendwie ein Produkt, was die Telekom da auf den Markt wirft für...
Ist das das mit diesen beiden Typen, die da bei dem dicklichen Verkäufer stehen und das schnurlose Telefon mit...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was anderes ist.
Ich halte mich nicht so häufig in diesen T-Punkt-Läden auf, ich weiß nicht.
Nein, das war im Fernsehen.
Das ist echt die Werbung mit Eni, die dann irgendwie... Eni, wo bist du? Hier, Robert. Diese Werbung ist das, genau.
Ja, die hypen das jetzt anscheinend auch so ein bisschen, was besonders gut ist oder vielleicht eigentlich eher nicht so gut ist. Die Telekom-Mitarbeiter werden nicht geschult, das habe ich ja vorhin schonmal angesprochen.
Man kann sich den Kram doch auch von denen installieren lassen, oder?
Ja, eben. Und das ist ja das Ding. Man bestellt sich dann halt so einen DSL-Anschluss mit diesem T-SINUS 130 DSL. Das wird dann installiert und da kommt dann halt so ein Telekom-Monteur vorbei und setzt das alles auf. Und ja, was ist denn, wenn der gar nichts weiß über Wave-Lanen, wenn er keine Ahnung hat, dass man da auch irgendwie eine Verschlüsselung einschalten kann?
Also das ist doch ein Telekom-Monteur.
Der hat sicherlich drauf, ne?
Hat er nicht?
Also da verlässt man sich vielleicht als Kunde drauf und muss ja nicht dieses 100-seitige Handbuch noch durchlesen. Ja, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass die keine Ahnung haben und da zum einen dieses Netz nicht absichern, indem sie diese WEP-Verschlüsselung einschalten und dann lassen sie auch noch dieses Passwort für diesen Access Point im Betriebszustand. Das kann man doch überall nachlesen, dass das 4 Nullen sind. Ja, man erkennt die Netze halt auch daran, dass da WLAN oder ANI steht, ich weiß es jetzt auch nicht genau. Ja, es ist jedenfalls sehr praktisch für die Leute, die unten auf der Straße sitzen und mal ein Netz brauchen oder eine Kinokarte.
Es ist doch noch praktischer, einfach dann vor dem Telekom laden zu warten, bis sich ein Typ so was kauft, mit dem mitzugehen, zu gucken, wo er wohnt.
Also das ist ja irgendwie so, man könnte ja noch sagen, wenn man sich selber kauft im Telekom-Laden und dann das Handbuch nicht liest, dann ist man halt selber schuld irgendwie. Aber das große Problem ist ja, wenn man sich halt, dass bei der Telekom inklusive Installationen bestellt und halt einfach davon ausgeht, so derjenige, der da kommt, der hat halt Ahnung von der Technik, weil das haben ja sonst nicht alle Ahnung von der Technik und es ist ja auch irgendwie kein Verbrechen, da keine Ahnung von zu haben. Und dann denkt man halt, da kommt jemand, der hat Ahnung davon, installiert das. Und klärt einen halt überhaupt nicht darüber auf, was es da für Risiken gibt. Und dann ist das halt mit diesem Default-Passwort nachher am Start. Und jeder im Haus kann da quasi drauf rumklicken. Was natürlich auch, also viele sagen jetzt vielleicht, na okay, was solls, ich hab eh ne Flatrate und interessiert mich nicht, kostet ja nix. Aber das Problem ist ja, dass über die Telekom, über T-Online gibt's jetzt inzwischen so viele Angebote, dass man diverse Sachen im Netz kaufen kann, einfach Geld ausgeben kann. Das Ganze wird halt einfach über die Telefonrechnung abgerechnet.
Und auch Leistung.
Ich muss nicht mehr irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Paybox mäßig.
Nö, gar nicht.
Du surfst da einfach auf die Seite und da gibt's so bunte Angebote und da kannst du dir verschiedene Dinge bestellen, wie Kinokarten, Visitenkarten. Du kannst die Leistungsmerkmale von deinem ISDN oder DSL-Anschluss ändern, zum Beispiel in minutengenaue Abrechnungen und solche ganzen Sachen. Und die Authentifizierung erfolgt einfach dadurch, dass du über deine DSL-Leitung sozusagen angewählt bist.
Abenteuer, Letzte Meile, die Probleme, die wir so mit der Telekom haben, insbesondere die Probleme, die die Telekom offensichtlich hat, Dinge anzuschließen und wenn sie sie angeschlossen haben, um konkret zu werden, Wavelan, das Ganze dann auch noch sicher zu machen. Was erwartet ihr eigentlich, wenn ein Telekom Techniker bei euch vorbeikommt von eben diesem Telekom Techniker? Guten Abend, Jan. Schon mal ein Techniker da gehabt? Schon mal ein Techniker von der Telekom bei dir gewesen?
Ne, den würde ich auch nicht bei mir zu Hause reinlassen.
Warum nicht?
Ne, ne, das würde ich dann schon selber machen. Also wie ihr schon sagt, die haben also wirklich keine Ahnung.
Naja, aber das sind hochbezahlte Fach... Also Fach...
Ja, die werden aber so bezahlt für den Anfahrtsweg, für das, was sie dann wirklich leisten bei dir zu Hause, ist ja dann wirklich lachhaft.
Was hast du nur für Probleme gehabt bisher?
Was ich für Probleme gehabt hab. Dann fangen wir bei den kleinen Geschichten an. Also, ich bin ISDN-Kunde seit der ersten Stunde mehr oder weniger. Und damals waren drei Telefonnummern inklusive gewesen. Wir hatten dann zwei Telefonnummern zusätzlich angeschlossen. Und dazu muss ich sagen, bei uns zu Hause war halt nebenbei, mein Vater hat selbstständig halt auch noch die Firma halt mit angeschlossen über zwei Telefonnummern. Irgendwann muss der halt dann ausziehen und wollte diese Nummern halt mit wegziehen. Und das hat auch eigentlich soweit wunderbar geklappt. Bloß die Telekom hatte uns dann zwei weitere Nummern zugeschaltet, uns aber niemals darüber irgendwie informiert. Und diese Nummern dann komischerweise auch ins Telefonbuch gestellt. Und wir hatten es natürlich nie gewusst, haben es über die Telefonanlage nie konfiguriert und waren dann halt nie erreichbar gewesen. Das erste Mal das erste Ding, was uns passiert ist. Das ist schon mal eine Kleinigkeit.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht, ja. Falsche Telefonbucheinträge sind immer eine lustige...
Meine Nummer stand mal hinter dem Namen einer Frau namens Uliana Wolf. Da haben bei mir ständig Leute anrufen, unter anderem auch die Oma von Uliana Wolf, die offensichtlich ihre Enkling schon ewig nicht mehr gesprochen hat. Das war echt krass. Und irgendwelche Sektenmitglieder und so.
Das war echt völlig bizarr. Waren Ufos involviert?
Nee, nee, nicht ganz so. Das war wirklich... Ja, nee, ich hab dann irgendwann mal gefragt, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich von mir? Lasst mich doch mal... Ja, wir sind so eine Gemeinschaft, das kannst du auch gerne mal im Internet angucken. Das war ziemlich seltsam. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ne, sorry, kenn ich nicht. Ja, hat die denn da mal gewohnt? Nee, weiß ich nicht. Ich bin hier nach der Sanierung eingezogen. Hier haben sie ja eine neue Nummer von Ullana Wolf. Das war echt ziemlich bizarr.
Das ist aber wie gesagt eins der kleineren Probleme, die ich mit der Telekom hatte.
Was war denn eins der größeren?
Ich meine, irgendwann wollte ich dann natürlich auch dieses tolle DSL-Angebot nutzen, die Telekom bzw. T-Online. Das sind ja offiziell zwei unterschiedliche Unternehmen. Da bin ich auch das gleiche Core Center, das was dich da bearbeitet, wenn du da einbruchst. Wollte ich das halt auch irgendwann in Anspruch nehmen und das habe ich dann auch ziemlich früh mehr oder weniger bestellt. Also wirklich damals, wo das noch sehr günstig war und du halt Modem und alles hinterhergeschmissen gekriegt hast und sagen wir mal so, das Modem und dieser tolle Splitter, den man dazu kriegt, der kam dann auch relativ schnell. Nur leider war das Modem halt defekt gewesen. Also man hat das schon an der Außenhülle gesehen, dass es kaputt war. Dann haben wir das einfach zurückgeschickt. Und der nette Jan ist dann halt zwischenzeitlich dann zur Bundeswehr einberufen worden, hatte dann halt wirklich kein großes Interesse mehr und keinen Bedarf und auch nicht mehr die Zeit dafür, sich darum zu kümmern, dass dann halt irgendwie Nachschub kommt. So haben wir dann mehr oder weniger elf Monate warten müssen auf, bis der Jan wieder von der Bundeswehr kam, bis dann das Modem halt bei uns dann irgendwann eingeflappert kam, nach zig Anrufen. Aber die Telekom hat immer schön fleißig halt die DSL-Grundgebühr von unserem Konto abgebucht, diese ganze. Also wir konnten die Leistung ja nie irgendwie nutzen. Ohne Modem und ohne Spiel, da geht es ja natürlich nicht. So, das haben wir dann irgendwann halt auch rückerstattet gekriegt. Frag mich nicht, wie ich das da irgendwie aus der Rechnung wieder rausgekriegt habe, aber irgendwie, ich glaub den jetzt einfach mal, dass das irgendwie wieder zurückgegangen ist auf unser Konto. Dann gab's so ein nettes Angebot von der Telekom. Und zwar heißt diese süße Telefonanlage Eumix 704 PC LAN. Das ist eine Telefonanlage.
Grinsende Gesichter hier im Studio.
Ganz bekannt.
Sieht so aus. Hallo Jungs, der am Telefon spricht mit euch?
Ja, ja, hör zu. Lass mich nochmal ausreden.
Er hat dich gefragt, ob dir die Anlage bekannt ist.
Schon öfters gehört.
Diese schöne Telefonanlage bietet halt die Möglichkeit, mehrere Computer über DSL an diese Telefonanlage anzuschließen und parallel dazu halt noch vier Telefone.
Aber immer nur einen Computer gleichzeitig.
Ja, das ist ja das Obstbure. Offiziell darf man das ja nicht. Mehrere Computer parallel über diese DSL Flatrate nutzen. Aber die Telekom sagt halt mehr oder weniger, ja, ja, können sie ruhig anschließen, kein Problem. Das wird mehr oder weniger toleriert. Ja, ja, in den Heim gebraucht soll das ja wohl irgendwie toleriert werden oder sein.
Hast du was irgendwie mitgeschnitten, diese Ansage?
Die offizielle, also die Telekom verkauft ja tatsächlich auch irgendwie Hubs und Switches und so für DSL und deren offizielle Ansage, warum sie das eigentlich tun, wenn man doch irgendwie das DSL eigentlich nur als einzelner Nutzer benutzen darf, war ja, du kannst ja mehrere Rechner anschließen, aber du darfst halt immer nur einen zurzeit nutzen. Das heißt, du kannst da zehn Rechner zu Hause stehen haben und du darfst offiziell immer nur einen davon angeschaltet haben und die anderen müssen immer schön aus sein.
Aber selbst dann, wozu baue ich mir zu Hause einen Netzwerk? Angenommen, ich baue mir eins. Wozu mache ich das, wenn eh immer nur ein Rechner an ist? Das funktioniert ja schon mal gar nicht.
Der Rechner muss sich automatisch schon durch die Telefonanlage, ich meine, er muss ja irgendwie durch die Telefonanlage und da dann auch schon gleich den Internetzugang hat, weil das dadurch automatisch konfiguriert wird, dann hat man den Salat mehr oder weniger. Naja, wie auch immer, diese schöne Telefonanlage, weiß ich, ob sie damals neu war oder diese Firmware einfach nicht irgendwie richtig war, diese Telefonanlage wurde von einem anderen Anbieter in Auftrag gegeben und für die Telekom produziert. Hatte aber mehr oder weniger den Nachteil, dass sobald du halt viel aus dem Internet gezogen hast, Downloads und dergleichen, und dann insbesondere über diese Tauschplassen, die ja jeder irgendwann mal irgendwo genutzt hat in irgendeiner gewissen Weise, stürzte diese Telefonanlage nach circa 200 Megabyte Download ab. 200 Megabyte über DSL sind relativ schnell erreicht. Das sind, weiß ich, wie lange dauert das? 1, 5, 2 Stunden?
Ja, also nicht wirklich lange.
Ja, und da man diese Telefonanlage ja bei uns wunderbar schön hinter der Wand halt integriert hat, um sie halt nicht immer schön blinkend irgendwie vor dem Bett zu sehen oder so, musste man immer schön aufschrauben, das Ding mit Stecker ziehen, wieder reinstecken und so weiter und sofort. Nun gut, dann habe ich mich halt um ein Austauschgerät gekümmert. Dieses kam dann halt auch irgendwann rein. Habe dieses angeschlossen, dann hin und her konfiguriert, pipapo, gleichen Probleme gehabt.
Das ist wie damals bei Metronet. Da konntest du keine Mails verschicken, die größer als ein MB waren. Das ist bestimmt genau dasselbe Prinzip.
Na ja gut, auch diese Telefonanlage hatte das Problem. Jetzt hatte ich dieses Problem gehabt, dass diese neuen Umtauschrechts, keine Ahnung, was da irgendwie in Anspruch kam, dass man halt, die Telekom sagte mir mehr oder weniger so, jetzt laut unseren AGBs können wir ihnen halt immer wieder, laut den ganzen zwei Jahren Garantiezeit, die ich habe, ein Austauschgerät zuschicken. Ich habe also nie irgendwie die Möglichkeit, diese Telefonanlage zurückzugeben. Dazu muss ich noch sagen, diese Telefonanlage habe ich subventioniert gekriegt und habe extra damals von diesem damaligen ISDN-300-Tarif auf einen XXL-Tarif aufgestockt. Das sind immerhin 5 Euro mehr im Monat. Habe dafür aber diese Subventionierung in Anspruch nehmen können.
Was ich ganz interessant finde, ist, dass du ja offensichtlich, auch wenn sie nicht unbedingt Auskünfte waren, die dir gefallen haben, doch halbwegs qualifizierte Auskünfte bekommen hast. Wie hast du das gemacht?
Ich habe mich eigentlich mehr oder weniger im Internet erkundigt, was denn da so wirklich das Sinnvollste ist für meinen Gebrauch und wollte halt möglichst die günstigste Variante. Deshalb halt diese Aufstockung auf den XXL-Tarif und dann halt kulanterweise, weil wir halt wirklich schon ziemlich lange und seit erster Stunde ISDN-Kunde sind, halt auch diese Subventionierung für diese Telefonanlage. Gut, wie gesagt, die zweite Telefonanlage hatte das gleiche Problem. Die dritte Telefonanlage hatte auch das gleiche Problem. Irgendwann hatte ich dann halt mal die Möglichkeit, auf der CeBIT hatte ich den Technik-Fuzzi der Telekom und den Kundenservice-Fuzzi der Telekom direkt neben mir stehen. Also die standen wirklich einen Meter voneinander entfernt. Glaubst du irgendwie, die beiden konnten sich miteinander austauschen? Nein. Denn wenn du beim Call Center an der Telekom anrufst, kriegst du den Kundenservice. Der ist ja kostenlos, 0800. Der ist aber nicht gewillt und nicht bereit und hat auch nicht die Möglichkeit, diese Information, die du dem Kundenservice gibst, irgendwie der Technik weiterzuleiten, sodass, wenn du bei der Technik anrufst und da das Problem nochmal schilderst, der das irgendwie dann nachvollziehen kann, dass du halt irgendwie schon mal damit Probleme hattest.
Naja, die Technik haben sie schon. Sie haben da so ein System, wo sie halt Kommentare reinschreiben können, was der Kunde irgendwie wollte, was sein Problem gewesen ist. Und das sieht dann auch die Technik.
Ja, nur ich hatte nur noch auf der Technik-Codline dann die Information bekommen, dass diese Bemerkungen oder wie auch immer nicht verzeichnet worden sind. Also so gab es halt keine Konversation zwischen diesen beiden Bereichen, sag ich jetzt mal.
Wir hatten eine Mail vor der Sendung zu dem Thema, da hatte jemand auch Probleme und der hat irgendwie auch wild rumtelefoniert und ist dann auch darauf gestoßen, dass da diese Kommentarfelder da existieren und alles. Und hat dann jemand mal gefragt von denen, was steht denn da eigentlich jetzt drinne? Was hab ich denn ihnen alles schon erzählt? Und mehr oder weniger war die Antwort, ja, sie haben ein paar Mal angerufen, aber wir haben ja eigentlich nur eine Verzeichnung von ihnen und die lautet Rechnungsnachfrage. Das war alles. Und das ist irgendwie ein Thema angerufen oder so.
Es gibt da wohl ein Feldkundenkontakt, wo immer eingetragen werden soll, was deshalb derjenige angerufen hat. Bei jedem einzelnen Gespräch soll das da eingetragen werden, weshalb derjenige angerufen hat, worum es ging und was ihm geraten wurde. Und im Allgemeinen ist es aber halt wohl so, dass dieses Feld überhaupt gar nicht benutzt wird. Und deshalb man halt immer wieder den Fall hat, dass man irgendwie bei der Hotline anruft und das zehnte Mal und wieder ganz von vorne anfangen muss, weil niemand eine Ahnung hat, worum es eigentlich geht.
Ja und wenn man wirklich Glück hat, wird man gleich aus der Leitung geschmissen. Wie ihr vorhin schon erzählt hattet. Übrigens dazu nochmal, schreibt euch ruhig die Namen auf, ob das nur Vornamen oder Nachnamen ist. Ihr hört immer wieder, wenn ihr da anruft oder irgendwie eine Beschwerde macht oder so. Ihr kriegt immer die Antwort, ja wir sind jetzt im Standort hier und da und wir haben so viele Schmidts, wir haben so viele Müller, das lässt sich doch nicht mehr nachvollziehen, wer jetzt da irgendwie am Telefon gewesen ist oder so. Also sich da irgendwie über einen Call Center Agent oder so was zu beschweren, das ist fast unmöglich.
Alles klar, Jan, danke für deinen Anruf. Du bist ja schon ewig in der Leitung und jede Menge Leute stehen hinter dir. Nicht so schneller erzählen müssen, okay? Gute Nacht! Bevor er wahnsinnig wird, roh. Hallo?
Ja? Ja, morgen hier ist roh. Ich hab da auch mal viel, viel Spaß gehabt mit Telekom, mit Acro und anderen Anbietern. Ja, ich fang mal vorne an. Ich hab mal einen Acro-Flatrate gehabt, als es das ganz frisch gab hier in Nürnberg. Und hatte dann das tolle Glück, nach Berlin zu ziehen. Dann dachte ich mir, hm, dann beanfragen wir halt noch ne Flatrate dort. Dann wohnt man in Berlin-Mitte, in einem Neubau, und denkt sich, ja, das sollte ja kein Problem sein, in der Hauptstadt dieses Landes mal einen ISDN-Anschluss zu kriegen. Es ist ja nicht mal Opal-Ghetto gewesen, da hätte man das ja noch verstehen können. Ja, so klar war es aber, darüber können wir kein Telefon machen. Aber dann kam ja noch das Beste. Acro ist ja so intelligent und stellt ja fest, man ist ja der gleiche Kunde und zieht einfach mal den kompletten Anschluss nach Berlin um. Schafft es aber nie, auf diese zwei Drähte mal irgendetwas zu schalten, was man mit dem NTBR in ein verwendbares ISDN umwandelt. Ja, dann hat man bei denen in der Datenbank, besser gesagt, sie haben, wie ich rausbekommen habe, drei Datenbanken, eine Datenbank für die Technik, eine Datenbank für die Abrechnung und eine Datenbank für den Service. Hier könnte wunderbar inkonsistent sein. Das heißt, in der Abrechnung stand, ich habe eine Flatrate, ich habe einen ISDN-Anschluss und das Ganze in Berlin und das funktioniert. Und ich habe dort DSL. Das Modem hab ich immer noch rumliegen, weil keiner entstanden ist, mir zu sagen, wo ich hin soll. Naja, ich habe dann Rechnungen bekommen für einen normalen ISDN-Anschluss. Mit einer 0911-Telefonnummer. Aber in Berlin. Also, das ist sehr konfus.
Moment, du hast eine Nürnberger Vorwahlrechnung für Berlin gekriegt?
Genau. Sehr geil.
Mit den korrekten Gesprächen drauf?
Nein, keine Gespräche drauf. Wie denn?
Er konnte ja nicht telefonieren.
Er hatte ein Amt drauf, in Anführungszeichen, aber davon konnte man nicht telefonieren. Der war wie, als hätten sie ihn gesperrt, wegen nicht Rechnung bezahlen.
Also du konntest sozusagen im Notfall die Polizei anrufen, aber sonst nichts?
Nein, das auch nicht.
Fahrlässig.
In dem Moment, wo man da irgendwelche Daten reingeschickt hat, dann hat der nette Monitor im ISDN einfach gesagt, Protocol Error Resetting, klack. Und dann war das Amt weg, dann war das Amt wieder da. Und dann sagte es nur, ich bin ein Amt und ich kann alles.
Das war jetzt Arcore, ja?
Das Problem hatte Arcore eine ganze Weile in Berlin, dass sie vielen Leuten dauernd versprochen haben, ja, wir legen...
Das Tolle daran war, Arcore sagte ja, der Grund war, na, die Telekom hat keine Pins frei. Na ja, die Vermittlungsstelle in Berlin war relativ neu. Aber das Tolle daran war, sie hatten keine Pins frei. Das heißt, sie hätten, in Anführungszeichen, zwei Drähte von meinem Anschluss ins Rack rüber und dort wieder ranmachen. Es ging also um einen Meter Kupferkabel, zwei Drähte auf dem einen Ende raufwickeln, auf dem anderen raufwickeln. Dann hätte das ja funktioniert. Na ja, ISDN konnte mir die Telekom aber auch nicht legen. So ein Analoganschluss, der hätte innerhalb von 14 bis einem Monat war die Schätzung, dass Telekom-Menschen gelegt werden können. Ja, Analoganschluss, was bringt mir der? Telefon hab ich auch so, so ein Handy, da kann man rumlaufen und das funktioniert auch so. Das war dann auch in zwei Jahren Berlin mein einziges Telefon, das irgendwie funktioniert hat. DSL in Berlin-Mitte?
Nee, das geht so gar nicht.
Das haben wir nicht. Das hab ich dann erst mal aufgegeben und hab dann eigentlich gleich mal noch zu den mittlerweile zwei Anfragen sozusagen, ich hätte gerne von ACORE, ich hätte gerne von der Telekom, hab ich doch dann mal einfach bei QSC angerufen und gefragt, ob die mir vielleicht irgendwie wenigstens Internet über diese zwei Drähte, die da aus der Wand kommen, legen können.
Erzähl dir die Sache jetzt nichts Falsches. Ich wollte da eigentlich hinwechseln demnächst.
Also das mit dem DSL-König QSC, Leute.
Nach einem halben Jahr, das war ja das Erstaunliche, von drei Anbietern war einer im Stande nach ca. 20 Telefongesprächen, 3 Anrufen bei der Regulierungsbehörde. Sie mögen doch bitte mal der Telekom so tief in den Arsch treten, dass sie stecken bleiben, dass da einfach mal ein Meter Kupferkabel von A nach B gelegt wird. So von REC zu REC. Naja, QSC hat es dann tatsächlich geschafft. Da kam natürlich dann der Telekom-Techniker. Ganz stolz. Und jetzt zeigen sie doch mal ihren Splitter her. Ja, wozu denn splittern? Das Modem nehmen, reinstecken, klingt wunderbar, 2, 3 MBit SDSL. Dann schaute der Telekom-Techniker blöd, schaute noch frustrierter und ging wieder. Weil eigentlich dachte er für das Geld, das in dem Fall glücklicherweise QSC übernimmt, also für seine, ich glaub, 50 Euro, die er normalerweise dafür bekommt, dass er zwei Dübel in die Wand haut und eine erste Telefondose montieren muss, im Extremfall. Das sind die teuersten Dübel auf diesem Planeten wahrscheinlich. Naja, dass man ja gar nicht bei ihm Kunde ist.
Aber immerhin hat er gemerkt, dass er verloren hatte.
Ja, das hat er eigentlich schon in dem Moment, wo er reinkam und irgendwie, ja, jetzt muss ich aber in den Keller unten messen. Ja, das hätten die School sagen müssen, da brauchen wir jetzt den Hausmeister. Der Hausmeister war glücklicherweise da und man hat ihn im Flur abgefangen, der sperrte dann den Anschlussraum auf. Na, da war ja aber schon alles fertig verkabelt. Also ging er frustrierter Dinge wieder und dann lief endlich mal der QSC-Anschluss. Es hat allerdings zu ungefähr eineinhalb Jahre zwei Briefe vom Anwalt und ein Gericht wäre zu teuer gewesen ohne Rechtsschutz gebraucht, bis ACO aufgegeben hat, versuchen Geld für einen ISDN-Anschluss von mir zu bekommen.
ACO hatte sowieso mal irgendwie so eine komische Praxis in Berlin, dass sie halt offensichtlich aus waren, ganz viele Kunden ganz schnell zu gewinnen, aber überhaupt gar nicht überall Anschlüsse legen konnten. Und sie haben jedem, der gekommen ist, haben sie gesagt, ja klar, können wir bei ihnen ISDN legen, überhaupt gar kein Problem. Und DSL kriegen sie auch drauf. Ja, das haben sie getan.
Die wollten mir das sogar schriftlich geben. Kannst du das reintun?
Ja, haben sie getan.
Und dann saß man da Monat um Monat und es passierte einfach nichts. Man hat keinen Anschluss gekriegt. Jede Menge. Ich kenne X-Leute, die jetzt so einen Stapel NTBAs in der Ecke stehen haben und DSL-Modems und sowas. Das hat man alles prima zugeschickt gekriegt, aber irgendwie eine entsprechende Leitung dazu hat man nie gekriegt von Aqua.
Ja, das ist typisch einfach. Egal welcher Telco, das ist irgendwie in Deutschland Servicewüste. Den besten Rat, den man da glaube ich geben kann, ist in der dritten Form von sich reden, immer möglichst höflich bleiben, möglichst technisch bleiben, sich sofort an den Techniker weiter verbinden lassen. Wenn das so einfach wäre, würde ich immer den Geschäftskundenservice anrufen.
Das darfste bei der Telekom auf gar keinen Fall machen.
Der Telekom funktioniert das. Wir legen ja so ISDN-Anschlüsse und sonstige Sachen als hinter der ersten Dose darf man ja offiziell erst ran als Firma. Heißt, wir montieren Telefonanlagen für Kunden, die der Telekom nicht zutrauen, dass sie das richtig konfigurieren können und so weiter. Dann steht man eben beim Kunde, was funktioniert nicht? Testtelefon ran? Funktioniert nicht. Dann rufen wir mal wieder die Telekom an. Na ja, wenn sie es überhaupt schaffen, ohne dass man ihnen alle drei MSNs, den vollen Vor- und Zunahmen, das Geburtsdatum und die Rechnungsnummer, die natürlich keiner parat hat, zu sagen, rauszufinden, welchen Anschluss man denn eigentlich meint, dann schaffen sie es teilweise innerhalb von zwei Wochen, jemanden zur Vermittlungsstelle zu schicken, um den Reset-Button zu drücken. Weil die stürzen hier bei uns in der Gegend zum Beispiel häufiger ab.
Hab ich so das Gefühl.
Heißt, da geht dann einfach nichts. Besonders, wenn neulich wieder mal Gewitter war, das heißt irgendwie ein Schwung NTV an die ganze Straße, dann tauschen.
Vielen Dank, Roh, und gute Nacht.
Dieses Gewitter letztens hat auch weitreichende Folgen gehabt. In Berlin das, meinst du? Ja, das hat irgendwie überall geruckelt.
Montag war das noch, oder?
Internet war down, die GSM war kaputt.
Genau, man konnte niemanden mehr anrufen, das Netz hat geruckelt, es war ganz scheuischlich und ich hab in der Unterhose auf meinem Balkon gestanden und hab Wasser über die Brüstung geschüppt. Super.
GSM war down, Internet war kaputt. Chaosradio 83 ist es, was ich hörte. Das Abenteuer Letzte Meile ist unser Thema und eigentlich wollten wir jetzt gerade über den Geschäftskundenvertrieb der Deutschen Telekom sprechen. Das stellen wir ein wenig hinten an, denn wir haben einen wesentlichen Anrufer hier in der Leitung zu begrüßen. Guten Abend Lars.
Ja, hallo.
Was ist dein Beruf Lars?
Ich habe keinen Beruf, ich bin Student und arbeite nebenher für T-Online als Techniker.
Nehmt ihn euch vor Jungs.
Was? Ich habe mal eine Frage zu den dreien, die da im Studio sitzen.
Wer sind das überhaupt?
Das sind Tobias, Thorsten und Robert. Und Robert T-Online.
Sind das Telekom-Mitarbeiter?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich so etwas trauen würden. Das ist das Chaos Radio hier. Das Chaos Radio wird hauptsächlich bestritten vom Chaos Computer Club.
Ach so, vorhin wurde gesagt, z.B. mit diesen WLAN-Points, dass man sich in den Netz einhaken kann und dann z.B. Premium-Inhalte bei der T-Online-Homepage kaufen kann und eben auf den Namen eines anderen, dass man identifiziert wird über die Leitung. Das ist immer richtig. Aber man kommt nur an diese Inhalte ran, wenn man das sogenannte Webkernwort benutzt. Ohne die läuft es gar nicht. Genauso, wenn man sein Alias ändern will, die Nutzungsdaten, Rechnungsdaten rein will, ähnliches tun will. Ohne dieses Kennwort kommen sie auch, wenn sie im Netz sind, also eingewählt sind über die entsprechende T-Online-Nummer, nicht nirgendswo raus.
Also da kenn ich ein gutes Gegenbeispiel. Wir hatten das im Club, wir haben im Club auch TDS-Elven, wir haben dann auch eine Svalve, was wir extra so konfiguriert haben. Und da hat jemand schicke Visitenkarten auf unseren Namen bestellt, die wir noch alle bekommen haben.
Okay, Visitenkarten weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich kann es jetzt nur sagen, weil wir mit diesem ganzen Premiumscheiß an der Technik nichts zu tun haben. Also jetzt nur wirklich diese Nutzungsgeschichten, Rechnungsdaten, Alias-Änderungen, ähnliches machen da. Und da ist es definitiv so. Also das kann ich nur wirklich sagen, dass es ohne dieses Laptime-Wort nicht geht.
Bei den Rechnungsdaten kann das sein, ja.
Wie gesagt, alles tarifliche, Tarifwechsel, alles, was wir da machen können. Und dieses, mit dem Routereinsatz, der Routereinsatz ist genau dann verboten bei DSL Flat. Oder jedenfalls steht das ganz klein in der Fußnote drin. Router kann man so das Argument widerlegen, wenn sie zum Beispiel einen anderen Tarif haben, Software M30, sonst was in der Richtung, geht der theoretisch auch mit dem Router. Oder einen volumenbasierten Tarif, den 5 GB, oder ähnlichen. Muss man ja nicht unbedingt...
Vielleicht kannst du uns ja mal eine Frage beantworten, warum die Telekom genau das nicht möchte, dass die Leute einen Router an ihrer TDS-Erleitung benutzen, betreiben und dadurch...
Das kann ich nicht sagen, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Entschuldigung, es geht um Geld. Es geht um Geld, die Telekom will sich möglichst frisch machen und darum will sie möglichst jeden einzelnen Bundesbürger als einzelnen Kunden begrüßen.
Aber das ist doch total unrealistisch.
Da marketingtechnisch natürlich was anderes dranhängt, das ist ganz klar.
Das ist die Post, Freunde, macht euch nichts vor.
Das will ich ja gar nicht bestreiten. Wie gesagt, ich will den Verein nicht in den Himmel heben, aber ich hab so ein paar Sachen gehört, die mir ein bisschen aufstoßen, wie gesagt. Also, dass da nicht alles gut läuft, das will ich auch gar nicht schönreden. Also, dass das nicht so ist.
Lars, was genau machst du denn da? Also, installierst du Anschlüsse auch?
Nein.
Das nicht?
Rein T-Online. Das heißt, sie haben eine T-Online-Technikrufnummer. Das ist die 980...
Das ist die, die Geld kostet, die man... Das finde ich auch, das ist vielleicht auch eine Frage. Vielleicht kannst du die beantworten. Warum muss ich eine gebührenpflichtige Nummer anrufen, wenn ein Dienst, für den ich Geld bezahle, nicht funktioniert?
Weil viele zu blöd sind, es zu benutzen. Es ist einfach so.
Was ist mit denen, die nicht zu blöd sind?
Eben. Dann, da haben sie recht. Aber ich kann, wie gesagt, aus meiner Erfahrung sagen, ich mache das schon drei Jahre lang. Um es mal milder auszudrücken, viele stellen sich einfach zu glatt an in vielen Sachen.
Ich meine, es sind User, es sind Endkunden. Die müssen keine Ahnung haben.
Ich sag das ja nicht zu den Leuten. Aber viele Leute machen Einstellungsprobleme, z.B. in der Software. Ich rede jetzt nur von der T-Online-Software, weil ich damit nur was zu tun hab. Ich rede nicht von irgendwelchen Hardwareanschlüssen oder irgendwelchen Geschichten, die bei Leuten installiert werden. Ich rede von den Leuten, die da anrufen. Und T-Online-Kunden sind nun mal nicht gerade die Power-User. Ausgenommen jetzt diese DSL-Leute und ähnliche Geschichten. Die normalen T-Online-Kunden, die wollen was Seriöses haben so ungefähr. Mittleren Alter, auch schon mal bis hoch in die 80 und älter. Das ist nun mal die Regel an der Hotline. Definitiv. Außer, wie gesagt, DSL-Kunden, die mit der Flatrate, wo auch die jungen Leute mit dranhängen. Aber das ist die Regel, ist wirklich so.
Wäre es dann nicht irgendwie eigentlich eine gute Variante für diese Leute, die ja dafür, für die Flatrate halt auch Geld bezahlen und zwar teilweise nicht zu knapp halt eine eigene Hotline einzurichten, die halt kostenfrei erreichbar ist?
Die Störungsstelle der Telekom, wenn es ein DSL, ein reines Leitungsproblem ist, ist kostenlos.
Nee, aber jetzt T-Online tatsächlich. Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel mal an ein Problem, was ich halt hatte, wo ich mich nicht mehr, wo ich halt, also ich hab auch zu Hause TDSL und benutzte auch die T-Online Flatrate und wo das halt nicht mehr funktioniert hat, weil irgendwelche Radio-Server breit waren oder ähnliches und ich bin halt immer zwischen Telekom und T-Online hin und her gebounst worden.
Da haben wir viel mit zu tun.
Jetzt zum Beispiel die Geschichte, wie gesagt, ich kann dir die Frage nicht beantworten, aber die Geschichte um nur ein Beispiel zu nennen, diesen DSL 1500. Die Telekom ruft die Leute an, möchten sie nicht DSL 1500 haben. Haben vorher 760 gehabt. Die Leute sagen einfach unwissend, probier ich mal aus, na klar. Haben aber mal eine Flatrate gehabt und die rufen an bei uns und haben Fehler R56B, ich hab Probleme bei der Identifikation. Ja, weil es keine Flatrate gibt für einen 1500er Anschluss. Das sind alles so Sachen.
Und die werden nicht am Telefon aufgeklärt, wenn denen das angeboten wird?
Die werden am Telefon aufgeklärt. Wir kriegen das relativ schnell bei uns mit, wenn bei uns keine Sperre eingetragen ist, kein Fehlversuch und ähnliches, sag ich mal, und ein falsches Scanmod bei uns in der Datenbank aufläuft, wenn sie was eintragen mit Absicht, dann wissen wir ganz genau, ja, das wird wohl ein 1500er Anschluss jetzt sein. Ja, und die Leute nichts geändert haben an der Software. Man kriegt sie auch nicht mit. Ich meine, die Leute kriegen sie auch nicht mit. Aber bei sich zu Hause kommt keiner nach Hause oder Ähnliches. Die legen da einen Schalter um in einer Vermittlungsstelle. Das war's.
Führt ihr eigentlich auch Buch darüber, wie die Leute drauf sind? Also gibt es eine Datenbank, in der möglicherweise drinsteht? Holger Klein ist jemand, mit dem ist nicht zu spaßen, weil der sofort den Chef anruft?
Also diese Leute von wegen Namen geben, ich geb immer gern meinen Namen, muss ich sagen.
Nee, ich mein, bin ich, weil ich schon ein paar Mal bei euch angerufen habe, bei euch in der Datenbank drin und bleibe da?
Es ist so eine Datenbank, die vorhin auch schon erwähnt wurde, wo so Kundenkommentare sind. Letztendlich, wo man was einträgt, was man mit dem Kunden gemacht hat und Ähnliches. Das trägt man da ein, aber wie gesagt, das wird manchmal mit mehr von manchen Leuten gemacht, manchmal weniger.
Bleibt das denn da auch stehen oder wird das irgendwann gelöscht?
Ja, also bei uns, wie gesagt, ich kann immer nur...
Gibt es bei euch explizit so ein schwieriger Kundeflag?
Da steht höchstens mal ein Kommentar drin. Da steht so intern drin. Der Kunde hat sich sehr aufgeregt, so und so. Wenn jemand vorher mit dem rumgeschrien hat oder was auch immer, das kommt auch vor. Wenn man beleidigt wird am Telefon oder ähnliches, dann schreiben das schon die Kollegen rein, um einen so innerlich vorzuwarnen. Das ist ja auch ganz normal. Weil ich habe auch keine Lust mich beleidigen zu lassen am Telefon aus Gründen, die ich vielleicht nicht so ganz nachvollziehen kann, die auch vielleicht von den Kunden falsch sind. Man versucht da ruhig zu bleiben. Es sind auch nur Menschen, die da sitzen.
Den Eindruck habe ich manchmal nicht. Wie ich an Telekom- und T-Online-Hotlines schon schlecht behandelt wurde, habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass da Menschen sitzen. Und ich bin wirklich freundlich, wenn ich da anrufe. Weil ich mir jedes Mal denke, die können alle nichts dafür.
Wie gesagt, ich kann es nicht generell sagen. Ich kann es von uns aus sagen, bei uns im Call Center ist es so, dass da wirklich Menschen sitzen. Also der größte Teil ist, es gibt natürlich auch Arschlöcher, die es überall gibt. Aber es will da keinem was Böses. Man sagt so sich, leck mich am Arsch, der da anruft, sag ich irgendwas, hier rufen sie da und da und dann tschüss. Also jedenfalls ist das nicht meine Einstellung da.
Grundsätzlich gilt natürlich immer, wenn man bei irgendwelchen Call Centers oder Hotlines anruft, dass man immer freundlich und sachlich sein sollte und nicht...
Wurde man ja auch geschult oder wurde man ja auch geschult?
Wurde man? Also beim Anfang?
Natürlich, bei uns war es zum Beispiel so, man hat, wie gesagt, ich bin Student eigentlich, man hat das nur nebenher. Wir hatten eine 2-monatige Anfangsschulung, aber auch zwischendurch bei uns ist andauernd immer eine Schulung, wenn es was Neues gibt. Also diese Geschichte von vorhin kann ich eigentlich so auch nicht stehen lassen. Welche?
Welche, welche, welche? Na die, Thorsten hat ja vorhin erzählt, die ungeschulten Techniker. Aber das bezog sich auf die Telekom.
Nein, es sind jetzt T-Online-Schulungen, meine ich jetzt damit. Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwelche am Messenger, was rumgebaut wurde, beziehungsweise auch am Organizer-Funktion, diese Webmail-Funktion bei uns auf der Seite, wenn da irgendwas geändert wurde, kommt Vorpaket bei T-Online. Diese Geschichten bei der Anmeldung, wenn da irgendwie was geändert wurde auf der Homepage oder Top-3-Passwort und alles so eine Geschichten, was die jetzt da eingerichtet haben, was jetzt relativ neu ist noch. Oder jetzt diese Homepage-Plus-Geschichte, die jetzt neu gekommen ist mit der Cebit. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon wisst, ich meine das für Leute, die sich professionell mit einer Homepage auseinandersetzen, nichts. Aber für so Anfänger ist es eben was, wo so eine Homepage-Baukasten und so ähnliches Geschichten dabei sind. Da wurden wir schon geschult. Also das ist nicht so, kam von oben und das war's dann, ja.
Lars, vielen Dank, das war alles sehr aufschlussreich.
Okay, ich finde alles gleich.
Eine letzte Frage habe ich noch an dich. Was würdest du sagen, wenn jetzt jemand ein Problem bei TierOnline hat und einfach das Gefühl hat, er erreicht bei TierOnline an der Hotline niemanden, der so richtig kompetent ist? Wie würdest du dem...
Ich würde als erstes immer darauf bestehen, dass wirklich immer ein entsprechendes Case festgemacht wird, was mit demjenigen gemacht wurde. Das heißt, die TierOnline-Nummer muss aufgenommen sein und die entsprechende Ausstattung vom Rechner und ähnliches abgefragt worden sein und darauf bestehen, dass das alles, was derjenige mit dem gemacht hat, notiert wurde. Und wenn derjenige nicht weiterkommt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, weil er eben nicht weiter weiß oder was auch immer, gibt es bei uns so ein Second Level. Da kann man immer noch hin. Die haben so eine erweiterte Datenbank für Fehler, die, sag ich mal, noch nicht, sag ich mal, abgesegnet wurden, wo die Lösung noch nicht offiziell ist, sozusagen. Wo sie auch mal in einer Registry drin rumschmieren können und ähnliches, was, sag ich mal, nicht...
Das heißt, ich sag dann demjenigen, den ich an der Hotline habe, verbinden sie mich doch bitte mal zum Second Level.
Oder Fachteam heißt das bei uns. Aber das muss derjenige im First Level sowieso machen, sobald er mit der Lösung nicht weiterkommt, die er da hat, offiziell für seinen Fehler. Und wenn er, wie gesagt, Unfreudlichkeit oder ähnliches erlebt an einer Hotline, dann ist meine Devise immer den nächsten Vorgesetzten, das ist der sogenannte Teamassistent oder Teamleiter, zu sprechen oder sprechen zu wollen. Und spätestens da hat man dann jemanden dran, der eigentlich von dem, was er da erzählt, auch ein bisschen Ahnung haben sollte. Spätestens da.
Ich hatte ja, wie gesagt, neulich gerade bei der Telekom dieses Erlebnis, dass ich nach dem Teamleiter gefragt hab, kann ich mal bitte den Teamleiter sprechen? Und die Antwort war, nö, können Sie nicht. Klick aufgelegt.
Aber das kann ich nur, also wenn man höflich fragt, ich möchte bitte den nächsten Vorgesetzten oder Teamleiter sprechen, die müssen's machen. Also offiziell ist jedenfalls die Ansage so.
Also ich hab höflich gefragt, weil das ist grundsätzlich so die Regel, wenn man bei solchen Hotlines anruft, immer sachlich bleiben und nie sich aufregen oder so.
Das ist sowieso immer schlecht.
So kommt man halt überhaupt nicht weiter.
Wenn du dich aufregst, also es funktioniert auch. Ich weiß gar nicht, das war auch nicht Telekom, sondern irgendwas anderes. Lars ist weg.
Er ist sabotiert worden.
Oder der Chef hat es mitgekriegt.
Aber er hat da doch nur Gutes erzählt. Wir halten fest irgendwie, es gibt auch gut geschulte und gute Mitarbeiter bei T-Online, die durchaus kompetent sind.
Genau, vielen Dank, Lars.
Und schauen, dass welche, wenn uns sonst noch irgendwelche Telekom-Mitarbeiter hören oder so, ihr könnt gerne anrufen.
Ruft uns an.
Genau, wir können auch im Zweifelsfall ein Effektgerät drüber legen, damit wir mit verstellter Stimme reden können. Nein, wenn du vorher sagst, ich weiß, es ist nicht ihre Schuld, aber ich bin so stinksauer, dass ich sie wahrscheinlich gleich anfahren werde, dann sagen die meisten auch, ja ist okay, sie sind mir ja gewohnt. Also mit Ansage geht es auch nicht mehr. Darfst du dem nur nicht übertreiben.
Also Call Center ist ein harter Job.
Aber auch nicht schlecht bezahlt. Meine Nachbarin arbeitet da, die verdient recht gut.
Also es gab auf dem Kongress auf dem letzten Vortrag von Fanny dazu, die arbeitet da auch irgendwie in einem Call Center. Ich glaube, es war irgendwas mit Stromanbietern. Und die hat einen Vortrag zu gehalten. Also die Bezahlung ist nicht so prall, wie man sich das denkt. Und der Job ist echt knochenhart. Und es zehrt echt an den Kräften, wenn man von Leuten angebollt wird. Das ist schon so. Man nimmt es mit.
Das ist echt ein harter Job.
Man wird den ganzen Tag fertig gemacht für Probleme, mit denen man eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat, wofür man gar nichts kann.
Harte Schule, ja.
Ich würde gerade den Regler hochziehen, jetzt ist deine Musik aus. Telefonieren wir eben weiter. Selber Schuld. Das Chaos Radio 83 ist hier. Und der Chaos Computer Club bestreitet das Chaos Radio. Darum heißt es so, für den Fall, dass noch mehr Leute zuhören wie Lars, die das gar nicht so genau wussten. Und das Chaos Radio gibt es immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Und heute ist unser Thema Abenteuer, Letzte Meile, 0331, 7791, sonst noch die Nummer der Fritzertlein.
Anke!
Nee, Anke!
Hallo Anke!
Willkommen, die erste Frau heute Abend, sehr schön.
Ach, immer dieser Kommentar.
Was denn?
Welcher Kommentar?
Die erste Frau heute hier.
Ja, offensichtlich gibt es mehr männliche Nerds.
Das stimmt nicht.
Die weiblichen, die haben nur keine Telefone. Anke, genau. Erlöse uns.
Also ich hab keine Anschlussprobleme gehabt bisher, zum Glück. Aber ich hab auch einen Papa, der Elektrotechnik studiert hat, zum Glück. Und mir das immer fein anschraubt und macht und tut, weil er auch der Meinung ist, dass die meisten wirklich keine Ahnung haben. Und er hat das aber auch nie beruflich gemacht, also jedenfalls nicht Telefonsachen da irgendwie anschrauben und so. Mein Problem ist jetzt folgendermaßen, neulich kam bei mir eine Rechnung rein ins Haus. Dachte ich, naja, stand Telekom drauf, Telekom-Rechnung wie immer. Reise auf und sehe, äh, Freenet.de, ist ja komisch. Was wollen die jetzt von mir? Und da krieg ich eigentlich immer, also auf der Telekom-Rechnung zusätzlich immer so, wird ja aufgeschlüsselt, ne? Welche Anbieter man angerufen hat, bla bla. Und dann hab ich mal näher drauf geguckt, weil das nur von Freenet.de war. Und da stand dann irgendwie, ja, 20 Euro noch was. Ich meine, zwar nicht viel, aber irgendwie auch irgendwie, ja, 2000, 2001. Dachte, hä, wir sind hier bei 2003, was wollen die von mir? Habt ihr da mal angerufen? Ja, und dann hieß es, ja, da ist noch eine Rechnung offen von 2000 und 2001. Irgendwie vom Freenet, weil ich das Internet ab und zu mal benutzt habe, bla, bla. Damals hab ich es halt noch sehr wenig benutzt und war ja auch nicht viel. Und da hab ich gesagt, na ja, aber ich hab immer meine Rechnung bei die Telekom bezahlt und darüber wurde ja auch Freenet bezahlt. Also das wurde immer gleich mit angegeben und dann hab ich das überwiesen und immer gut. Ja, kam ja auch keine Rechnung mehr dann. Also wenn ich was nicht bezahle, die kommen ja dann immer gleich ein und wollen einen krallen. Und da meinten die, ja, das kann sein. Die waren auch sehr nett bei Freenet. Also das muss ich auch sagen, da war ich erstmal begeistert. Die meinten, ja, das ist jetzt schon öfter vorgekommen, dass Leute anrufen, die das bezahlt haben. Aber sie können bei der Telekom nichts machen. Da meinte ich, wieso können sie nichts machen? Das ist ja ihr Geld, nicht meins. Ich hab ja schon bezahlt. Nee, nee, ich müsste selber die Unterlagen zusammensuchen, ein Freenet schicken, und die können dann bei der Telekom das dann sozusagen, naja, einklagen, weiß ich nicht, aber zurückfordern. Und wenn ich das jetzt nicht mache, dann wird mir irgendwie der Anschluss irgendwann gekappt oder so. Also nicht jetzt meinen Telefonanschluss, sondern den Internetanschluss.
Früher war alles besser.
Das heißt, so die Telekom hat's echt versäumt irgendwie, das Geld, was du ihnen gegeben hast, um Freenet zu bezahlen, einfach weiterzureichen, haben das selber eingekriegt.
Ja, und da hab ich mir dann überlegt, wenn die das bei einer Million Menschen machen, das ist ja nicht viel in ganz Deutschland jetzt. Da kann man mal schnell Multimillionär werden.
Das machen die doch ohnehin. Mehr als die Hälfte aller Rechnungen ist übernöt, aber immer nur um ein paar Pfennige.
Die Devise der Rechnungsstelle, das schlagen wir mal drauf und dann sehen wir mal, ob er es bezahlt, und wenn nicht, dann halt nicht.
Ja, das ist schon eine alte Ente, aber ich meine, das ist echt frech, weil Freenet jetzt richtig schon in Kassomäßig, also die gleich eine Mahnung schicken und so. Und ich hab gesagt, tut mir leid Leute, also ich hab hier wirklich nichts gemacht. Und ich komm hier vor wie ein Schwerverbrecher für 20 Euro und hast du nicht gesehen? Und das find ich jetzt echt ein bisschen peinlich. Und die haben gesagt, ja und es tut uns leid und wir können nichts dafür und die Telekom können wir auch nicht belangen. Und da denk ich mir, wo sind wir hier eigentlich?
Hast du eine Rechtsschutzversicherung?
Ja, nee, mein Freund ist ein Rechtsanwalt, aber der ist gerade nicht in Berlin. Aber er war noch in der Kanzlei tätig.
Und was hast du dir jetzt überlegt, was du jetzt machst?
Ja, ich hab auch die Erfahrung gemacht, wenn man da anruft und sich weiter verbinden lässt und den Teamleiter sprechen will und so weiter, man kommt nicht weiter. Also die sagen nö, das ist wieder Sache des Freenets. Also das ist nicht unser Pech.
Aber du kannst nachweisen, dass du das Geld bezahlt hast.
Das muss ich da nachweisen.
Das kannst du ja, oder?
Also hast du denn diese alten Rechnungen noch?
Nicht alle, glaube ich. Ich bin nämlich ein paar Mal umgezogen in den drei Jahren. Also mindestens zweieinhalb Mal oder so.
Na gut, aber du hast ja alle Telefonrechnungen bezahlt und die Telekom macht es im Kassobastar.
Ich kapiere das nicht.
Vielleicht kann das der Telekom das in Rechnungsstellen. Mal sehen, was sie dann sagen.
Ich kapiere das auch nicht. Ich habe zwar nicht Elektrotechnik studiert und den ganzen Scheiß, aber bisher verstehe ich noch, dass das irgendwie nicht ganz so richtig ist und wenn wirklich Leute auch nur 10 Euro bezahlen, weil sie sich sagen, kein Bock, die ganzen Rechnungen zusammenzusuchen oder das Freenet zu schicken, dann wären da wirklich Multimillionäre geschaffen. Und das kann ich irgendwie nicht einsehen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ich machen soll, weil ich weiß jetzt schon, ich kriege mich tierisch auf, ich rufe da an und dann werde ich wieder von Linz nach Kunst und von Grety nach Pleti geschickt. Und dann bin ich immer noch nicht weiter. Und dann ist irgendwann Freenet, kommt ein Kassoverfahren und dann habe ich nochmal 5 Euro drauf und nochmal 10 Euro drauf. Und bla bla. Und da habe ich echt keinen Bock mehr drauf. Und irgendwie bin ich da jetzt schon voll abgenervt.
Das ist eigentlich ein Fall für die Regulierungsbehörde.
Was sollte man meinen?
Also die bei DirektTP sind erstaunlich responsiv und die wissen auch immer Bescheid und versuchen irgendwie den Leuten so schnell wie möglich zu helfen. Und ich glaube, ich würde einfach mal bei DirektTP anrufen und den Fall schildern.
Genau, da gibt es nämlich genauso eine Hotline, wo du anrufen kannst und denen den Fall schildern kannst. Und die sind da sehr an Problemlösung, um Problemlösung bemüht.
Habt ihr da irgendwie eine Nummer für?
Die Nummer habe ich jetzt gerade nicht, aber du kannst auf, wenn du noch Internet hast, kannst du auf www.rekttp.de Wie wird denn das Buch stabiliert? regtp, wie Regulierungsbehörde für Telekommunikation und Post.
Aha.
Genau, da kannst du mal draufklicken und da gibt es so eine Verbraucher-Hotline quasi, wo man anrufen kann und das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Vielleicht können sie dir weiterhelfen oder zumindest erzählen, wie du dich zu verhalten hast, rechtlich in der Situation.
Ja, weil es kann nicht sein, dass ich jetzt stundenlang mich hinsetze und alle Orner durchwühle und dann fehlt eine Rechnung und das muss die Rechnung sein, da haben sie nicht bezahlt. Also da hab ich echt keine Lust. Außerdem fahre ich in zwei Wochen nach Thailand und für einen Monat und noch andere Sachen sofort zu machen.
Echt, wo fährst du denn hin?
Nach Bangkok erstmal und dann ein bisschen rum.
Was heißt das für ein Studio?
Ja, ja, aber trotzdem, es war echt wieder mal toll. Weil ich jetzt echt keine Zeit dafür habe, ich weiß sowieso, dass eine Rechnung wieder fehlt. Oder zwei oder drei von den letzten drei Jahren irgendwie. Oder von diesen zwei Jahren da halt. Ich muss auch sagen, ich seh das nicht ein, wenn ich fast nicht bezahlt habe.
Anke, hast du was zu schreiben? Sie, schreib mal auf, wir haben die Hotline mittlerweile. 018 05, 5 sind 24 Centiminuten.
12 Centiminuten, 24 find ich die Minute.
018 05, 10 10 00. Also zweimal die 10, 018 05, zweimal die 10, 00 von 9 bis 15 Uhr.
Geile Zeiten, so möchte ich auch mal arbeiten.
Nee, danach machen die den ganzen Papierkram. Das ist nicht so früh.
Also Rechnung schreiben ja.
Anke, danke für deinen Anruf und Kopf hoch. Und falls sich da irgendwie was tut, nach deinem Anruf bei der Regulierungsbehörde, würde uns das interessieren.
Genau, dann kannst du uns vielleicht eine Mail schicken.
Genau, Chaosradio AG. Alles klar, mach's gut, Anke. Tschüss und viel Spaß in Thailand. Wir hatten doch gesagt, hier mögen doch bitte mal Telekom-Mitarbeiter anrufen. Ich war nicht, nicht? Hallo, Gwen.
Du warst bei der Telekom?
Warum?
Warum nicht mehr? Betriebsbedingte Kündigung.
Ach so, also du hast nicht irgendwelche Geheimnisse verraten?
Was hast du denn gemacht bei der Telekom?
Ich war längere Zeit für die DSL-Technik zuständig, sprich die ehemalige 4433 am Ende, die mittlerweile nächste Woche kostenpflichtig wird, wenn ich mich nicht treue. Und zuletzt dann halt für die Endgeräte der Telekom, in der technischen Support zuständig. Und ja, hab beides dann nebenbei so gemacht, da wo halt Not am Mann war. Und hab eigentlich so alles durchgemacht, was man dadurch machen kann.
Und hattest du da auch Kundenkontakt?
Sicher, ich hab reinen Kundenkontakt gehabt, ich hab richtig im Core Center gesessen, hab First und Second Level gemacht, je nachdem wo ich schon eingesetzt war. Und ja, zuletzt halt dann bei den Endgeräten und eigentlich hauptsächlich DSL-Technik.
Und was waren da so deine Erfahrungen?
Ja, es ist halt unterschiedlich. Bei der DSL-Technik war halt eigentlich die Freundlichkeit der Kunden war eigentlich sehr positiv, weil es wahrscheinlich auch kostenlos war. Geh ich mal von aus. Man konnte den Kunden eigentlich immer recht gut helfen, bis auf ein paar Fälle anfangs von der DSL-Technik. Wo die Störungen halt extrem waren in Dortmund und in den großen Städten. Da war dann halt der Kunde etwas sauer, verständlicherweise auch. Ich lebe ja auch zu, aber man konnte halt nichts machen, wenn dann irgendwelche Server abschmieren.
Und wie war da so eure Verfahrensweise? Was wir hier schon mal angesprochen hatten, dass man immer wieder von Neuem anfangen muss und dass so Sachen wie Kundenkontaktfelder und so was nicht ausgefüllt werden. Habt ihr das immer, seid ihr da angehalten worden, so was aufzuschreiben und habt ihr das gemacht?
Also offiziell mussten wir halt für jeden Call, den wir gemacht haben, ein Ticket erstellen, beziehungsweise ein Ticket erstellen oder halt die Kundendaten neu erfassen und dann halt auch protokollieren, was wir mit dem Kunden gemacht haben. Das haben jetzt nun alle nicht gemacht. Das sehe ich mal von aus, weil ich habe gemerkt, dass dann halt die Tickets zählen, die wir dann so genannt haben. In der Regel müssten wir es machen, aber das haben wohl nicht alle gemacht. Was natürlich auch nicht immer geht, wenn der Kunde eben entsprechend geladen ist und nicht mit seinen Daten rüberkommt. Das ist schlecht mit dem Kunden, irgendwie was zu machen und einzutragen.
Und wie sieht es mit Schulungen aus?
Also zu Anfangszeitpunkt haben wir halt eine Schulung bekommen in beiden Gebieten. Und nach und nach immer eine kleinere Schulung. Wenn was Neues kam, wie jetzt die DSL 1500 oder irgendwelche neue Techniken, neue Geräte etc. haben wir halt auch eine Schulung bekommen. Beziehungsweise es wurde dann einer oder zwei wurden geschult. Und die haben das dann in der Gruppe quasi als Schulung nochmal weitergegeben. Ich hab's dann auch irgendwann nochmal gemacht mit einem Kollegen, der da nicht so weiter wusste.
Also welcher Bezirk? Oder Stadt, wie auch immer?
Also ich sitz in Bremen und hab das alles in Bremen gehabt. Je nachdem dann mit den Kollegen, die dann halt im Hintergrund sitzen und dann halt dann sich die Technik auch mal zur Lage führen.
Das hängt dann wohl auch vom Teamleiter ab. Wenn der entscheidet, es gibt jetzt eine Schulung, dann gibt es auch eine Schulung.
Ja, beziehungsweise es wurde auch eine oder zwei Mal von einer Niederlassungsleitung angeordnet. Aber im Endeffekt macht das der Teamleiter beziehungsweise dann das Team sagt, wir brauchen eine Schulung.
Wir stellen fest, also die Schulungsmaßnahmen sind auch regional bedingt. Und nicht unternehmensübergreifend.
Dankeschön, gute Nacht. Wir müssen Nachrichten machen. Alex hält bitte auf jeden Fall noch aus, denn Alex hat auch bei der Telekom gearbeitet. Wir machen jetzt Nachrichten, dann hören wir ein bisschen Musik, weil wir wollen auch eine Zigarettenpause machen. Und wenn wir das gemacht haben, dann telefonieren wir mit Alex, der, wie ich gerade schon mal sagte, bei der Telekom gearbeitet hat.
Wenn Fritz ein Fürstenwalder, dann 101, 5.
2, 5 Zwölf.
Fritz Info.
In der Nacht erwarten uns wenige Wolken. Bei Dienstwerten zwischen 13 und 9 Grad am Tage wirds heiter und trocken die Höchstwerte zwischen 22 und 26 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Boehner.
US-Präsident Bush hat die Europäische Union aufgefordert, ihren Widerstand gegen gegentechnisch veränderte Lebensmittel aufzugeben. Auf einem Regierungstreffen sagte Bush, Genfood sei sicher und gesund. Die EU lehnt die Öffnung ihrer Märkte für Genlebensmittel ab. Bei den Tarifverhandlungen für die Druckindustrie gibt es eine Einigung. Die Beschäftigten erhalten in diesem Jahr 1, 5% und im nächsten Jahr 1, 7% mehr Geld. Das teilte die Gewerkschaft Verdi und der Verband der Druckindustrie mit. In der liberianischen Hauptstadt Monrovia hat es eine schwere Explosion auf dem Gelände der US-Botschaft gegeben. Dort sind offenbar mehrere Granaten eingeschlagen. Auf dem Gelände haben tausende liberianischen Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge Zuflucht gesucht. Über Tote und Verletzte weiß man noch nichts. Die Rauschgiftexperten der UNO haben die Partydroge Ecstasy zum Staatsfeind Nr. 1 erklärt. Es sei besorgniserregend, dass viele Menschen den Missbrauch synthetischer Drogen scheinbar tolerierten. Insgesamt gehe die Produktion von Drogen weltweit aber zurück. Und der Verkehr auf Rütz, der hat keine Meldung, deswegen gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist der einzige Sender weltweit mit einer mobilen Toilette. Die Fritz-Toy-Toy-Dixi-Toilette.
Außen Pritz und innen. Ein Riesenspaß für Groß und Klein. Die Fritz-Toy-Toy-Dixi-Toilette. Diesen Sommer unterwegs in Berlin und Brandenburg.
Und im Radio.
Wir gehen los. 83. Ihr hört Fritz, denn da läuft das Chaosradio. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Telefonanlage gestört ist. Alex, bist du noch dran? Alex, Alex, Alex? Schade, Alex ist nicht mehr dran. Alex hat nämlich auch bei der Telekom gearbeitet. Auch an denen hätten wir einige Fragen. Alex, ruf bitte nochmal an. Alle anderen Telekom-Mitarbeiter melden sich natürlich auch gerne anonyme oder pseudonyme unter 0331 70 97 110. Wo waren wir eben eigentlich stehen? Genau. Warum soll man nicht beim Geschäftskundenservice der Deutschen Telekom anrufen, wenn man da möglicherweise besser oder schneller bedient wird?
Ja, soll man nicht anrufen. Es gibt für die Privatkunden zwei Bezirke, zumindest hier in Berlin. Die haben jede Menge Mitarbeiter, die da auch einspringen können und das geht dann auch recht flott. Aber im Geschäftskundenbereich, da gibt es ein Team für ganz Berlin und das besteht so aus gut 20 Mitarbeitern. Und die haben entsprechend zu tun, die sind ganz schön ausgelastet.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Schon.
Übrigens, Tobias, du hattest eine Woche Probleme, der Stefan, Stefan? Ja, du hattest 14 Monate Probleme?
Okay, du gewinnst.
Ich hab mich wirklich richtig klasse eben amüsiert mit den beiden Telekom-Leuten, die er da ran hatte. Die scheinen in meinem Leben immer mit den falschen Leuten Telefon zu haben.
Das ist, was ja auch super ätzend ist, wo du das gerade sagst. Ich hab mich dann auf das Thema gefreut heute Abend. Dann war mein Telefon ausgefallen und mein DSL ist sowieso gestört. Dann hab ich gedacht, ha ha, jetzt hol ich mir nochmal Erfahrungsberichte. Super freundlich. Da angerufen hat, ja, hier, Telefon geht nicht mit dir. Oh, das tut uns sehr leid. Ich guck mal eben, ah, der Fehler liegt garantiert auf unserer Seite. Was es genau ist, können wir Ihnen noch nicht sagen. Die waren total nett.
Ja, von der Sache her sind die ja auch nett.
Von der Sache her sind die ja auch nett.
Von der Sache her sind die ja auch nett. Also unsere Geschichte war, dass wir uns in 2000 DSL bestellt haben. Ging alles wirklich richtig klasse, nett, angerufen, schriftlich hingeschickt. Dann will man ja nicht sofort zwängeln. Dann haben wir so drei Monate gewartet. Dann hab ich dann noch mal freundlich angerufen. Dann hieß es ja klar, kein Problem und kommt. Und wir haben noch geringfügige Schwierigkeiten. Dann haben wir drei Monate später wieder angerufen. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja, also wir müssen ihnen leider mitteilen, zu ihnen ist es nicht möglich DSL zu legen. Aber es dauert noch drei Monate und dann geht es wahrscheinlich.
Du wohnst wo?
In Berlin Schöneweide.
Schöneweide, aha.
So, dann haben wir drei Monate später wieder angerufen. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja, es würde ihnen leid tun, aber sie hätten keinen Auftrag von uns. Dann haben wir natürlich wieder einen neuen Auftrag gegeben und haben dann wieder drei Monate gewartet. Und ich muss wirklich zugeben, ich war echt immer noch freundlich. Und dann haben sie uns mitgeteilt, ja, es würde ihnen also schrecklich leid tun, aber in dem gesamten Bezirk bei uns wäre es nicht möglich DSL einzurichten. Nun müssen wir dazu sagen, dass fünf Häuser neben uns ein Internetcafé ist.
Ja, bestimmt kein DSL.
Doch, da wir die nämlich gut und privat kennen, habe ich die dann mal gefragt, die haben dann sofort auch abgewunken. Und dann habe ich der netten Dame am Telefon gesagt, dass eben wie gesagt fünf Häuser neben uns ein Internetcafé wäre. Und da ich dann da versuchte schlau zu sein, habe ich mir sogar deren Telefonnummern mitgenommen und habe ihr dann die Telefonnummern gesagt. Denn sie hat natürlich am Telefon gesagt, das ist nicht möglich, bei ihnen ist kein Internetcafé. Und dann habe ich ihr die Telefonnummer von dem Internetcafé gesagt und dann hat sie wahrscheinlich in ihrem Computer nachgeguckt und hat gesagt, oh, da ist ja doch ein Internetcafé. Ja, so habe ich gesagt, das sehe ich auch so, aber deswegen hätten wir das auch gerne. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, dann würde sie das nochmal nachvollziehen. Und dann habe ich wieder drei Monate gefahren.
Wir sind jetzt bei wieviel? 9 oder 12 Monaten? Wo sind wir jetzt? Sind wir jetzt bei 9 oder 12 Monaten mittlerweile?
Du kannst das mal so eine Woche noch draufrechnen. Ich habe das jetzt nicht chronologisch vor mir liegen. So, und der letzte Anruf, und das waren dann halt wirklich ca. 14 Monate, können auch 13, 5 gewesen sein, dann hat die Dame zu mir gesagt, ja, also jetzt könnte es sein, dass es in ein paar Wochen bei ihnen funktioniert. Und dann habe ich zu ihr gesagt, das hätte ich gerne schriftlich. Das war schätzungsweise mein Fehler. Denn daraufhin hat sie zu mir gesagt, also schriftlich ist bei ihnen überhaupt nichts möglich.
Sie können schicken, was sie wollen, wir werden alles ignorieren.
Keine Spuren hinterlassen.
Genau, an dem Tag hatte ich dann aber glaube ich einen schlechten Tag, denn dann habe ich zu ihr gesagt, es kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein, dass ein Unternehmen wie ihr es nicht irgendwas schriftlich machen kann. Denn sie hatte nämlich zwischendurch wiederum unseren Antrag verloren und sagten dann, aber wenn wir das jetzt aufnehmen, dann dauert es nur noch ein paar Wochen. Und dann hätte ich das gerne schriftlich. Daraufhin hat sie zu mir gesagt, ähm, nee geht nicht. Daraufhin habe ich zu ihr gesagt, passen Sie auf, wenn ich zu einer Currywurstbude gehe und sage, ich möchte nächste Woche 25 Currywürste geliefert haben, schafft es selbst die Currywurstbude mir das schriftlich zu geben. Daraufhin ist meine Frau verlachend vom Stuhl gefallen fast. Ich habe angefangen zu brüllen und die Frau am Telefon hat aufgelegt. Dann haben wir Folgendes gemacht, weil man redet ja dann so im Bekanntenkreis, das kennt man ja dann wahrscheinlich, und jeder guckt einen dann immer so ein bisschen mitleidenswert an. Und man fängt halt schon selber an zu denken, vielleicht macht man selber was falsch. Mittlerweile war ich dann schon irgendwo der Meinung, vielleicht geht es ja wirklich nicht. Und hab dann also von einem Bekannten, das vielleicht so als Info wie die Geschichte halt ausging, der mittlerweile Humberte ist.
Ah, gratuliere.
Ja, von der Telekom.
Superklasse. Wobei, da kommt die Telekom auch nochmal drunter vor. Wir haben dann von einem Bekannten an sich Werbemail bekommen, auf die gebe ich eigentlich nicht viel, von sicherlich bekannt NGI aus Hamburg, die ja mal so einen ziemlichen Crashwall hingelegt haben, mit einer Flatrate.
Das waren doch die mit diesem komischen Bogen, mit dem Sternchen am Nudel.
Die haben sich dann aber irgendwie neu formiert und weißt du, wenn du so einen Tag hast, wo du auf der einen Seite dich mit den Leuten dann rumstreitest und dann hast du aber so eine Mail und dann denkst du jetzt, egal, du musst jetzt irgendwas tun. Und hab denen also eine Mail geschickt, die sitzen in Hamburg, die haben mir innerhalb von zwei Stunden per Mail zurückgeschickt. Kein Problem, ist möglich. Da hab ich natürlich noch nicht dran geglaubt. Und jetzt ohne Flux, das hat von wirklich dieser Mail, inklusive der Prüfung bis zu, jetzt sind wir wieder bei der Telekom, dass der Telekom-Mensch, der natürlich von denen auch nur angemietet ist, bis zu uns nach Hause gekommen ist, hat es drei Wochen gedauert. Der tauchte dann hier auf von der Telekom. Das ist vielleicht auch noch mal ganz gäckig. Das muss ich sagen, das habt ihr eben schon mal gesagt, von wegen mit älteren Mitarbeitern der Telekom, dass die eigentlich wirklich sehr nett und auch sehr erfahren sind oder so. War also zumindest bei dem auch meine Meinung, das war der erste Nette. Der hat dann hier bei uns diese Leitung des im Prinzip Fremdanbieters gelegt. War wie gesagt super nett, hat auch alles ganz ordentlich gemacht, hat dann irgendwas, ich bin da nicht so der Fachmann, irgendwas ausgemessen und hat gesagt, oh, das sieht schlecht aus.
Er hat die Dämpfung, die Dämpfung wahrscheinlich.
Ich bin dann mit dem durch den Keller, nicht gerobbt, aber da rumgelaufen und dann hat er hier oben irgendwie was rumgeschraubt und hat diese Buchse an die Wand gemacht und hat das Modell daran getan, was wir ja von denen dann zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen haben. Und hat dann da was weiß ich, irgendwas ausgemessen und hat gesagt, nein, das sieht er ja ganz dramatisch und also sie kriegen hier maximal die halbe DSL-Leistung und wenn überhaupt. Und da war ich, muss ich wirklich sagen, schwer bedient, weil in dem Moment glaubt man so einem Menschen das. Also lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, der ist dann gegangen und wir haben dann angefangen zu surfen. Wir haben einen DSL-Durchsatz, der deutlich höher und schneller ist über dem, wie er überhaupt angeboten wurde, was natürlich dann schon wiederum im Endeffekt recht erfreulich ist.
Hast du mal auf die Rechnung geguckt, was du da bezahlst?
Das ist wirklich okay. Ich kann dir jetzt genau den Betrag nicht sagen. Es ist vom Rechnungsbetrag her natürlich etwas teurer als das von der Telekom. Aber ich muss dir ganz ehrlich sagen, dafür, dass ich da geringfügig mehr bezahle, dafür aber auch in Richtung von Hotline und Service.
Egal, du hast die Telekom nicht mehr am Hals, ist so super.
Das ist überhaupt das Größte, natürlich. Aber wenn du dann halt natürlich auch noch mit einem Unternehmen, ein Unternehmen, das von der Hotline und vom Service her wirklich richtig klasse ist, richtig freundlich, dass du einen super Durchsatz hast. Wir hatten in den anderthalb Jahren, seitdem wir diese Flatrate von denen jetzt haben, ich glaube, ein einziges Mal einen Ausfall über zwei Stunden. Den haben sie dann drei Wochen vorher schon angekündigt.
Schlecht, das sind ungefähr 150 Ausfälle weniger als ich habe. Und ich habe DSL seit März.
Ja, und das eben im Prinzip wirklich noch mal zu der Thematik der Telekom. Ich muss einfach sagen, was mich einfach damals sehr geärgert hat, war die, und da muss ich halt den Menschen, die da vorher angerufen haben, ob Third Level oder Second oder First Level, war die, ja weiß ich nicht, dass ich mich in keinster Weise darauf verlassen konnte, was die mir erzählt haben. Hätten die zu mir gesagt, es geht nicht, es ist okay, weil dann kann ich damit leben. Dann hab ich eine klare Information. Aber von es geht nicht über es geht doch, und wir haben ja einen Aufrag verloren und jetzt haben wir ihn wiedergefunden, da muss ich sagen, ist schon ein bisschen nervig. Ist nicht schlecht.
Stefan, vielen Dank. Tschau. Die haben bei mir angerufen von der Telekom. Ich weiß gar nicht, seit wann gibt es DSL? Als es rauskam, hab ich es direkt bestellt. Ich hab da über drei Jahre dann drauf gewartet. Und da hab immer auf diesem Webding da diese Abfrage stand. Jaja, geht, super. Kannst du sofort bestellen. Dann hab ich es bestellt, dann kam drei Tage später eine Mail, wo drin steht, ne, da haben wir uns irgendwie dann doch ein bisschen geirrt jetzt. Also ist nicht. Alle zwei, drei Monate hab ich das immer wieder neu gemacht. Bestellt, bestellt, bestellt. Und irgendwann hab ich es mir abgeschminkt, hab sogar mein ISDN abgeschafft, weil ich so sauer war, und dann immer nur Analog Modem eingewählt. Ähm, kurz vor Weihnachten klingelt das Telefon bei mir. Ich meld mich nicht mit meinem Namen, sondern wünsche den Leuten immer freundlich einen guten Tag. Guten Tag.
Ja, Holger Klein.
Ja, hier ist die Deutsche Telekom. Guten Tag. Hast du wieder irgendein Gerät angeschlossen, was du nicht hättest anschließen sollen oder was? Da haben sie doch rausgekriegt, dass du in den 80ern ein nicht zugelassenes Telefon benutzt hast. Ja, äh, sie haben sich ja mal für DSL interessiert. Das wär jetzt verfügbar. Und sie werden es nicht glauben, wenn sie das jetzt noch bestellen, dann kriegen sie sogar noch das Modem so billig, weil ab Januar wird er teurer. Und das hat gestimmt. Der hat mich nicht belogen und hat sogar seinen Namen nochmal extra gesagt für den Fall, dass irgendwas nicht in Ordnung geht.
Respekt.
Das geht mir so auf die Nerven, dass ich in letzter Zeit keinen Ärger mit denen habe. Irgendwas stimmt oder nicht?
Das Pressefleck.
Ich sag dir, die haben das Pressefleck bei dir gesetzt.
Das kann nicht sein. Das kann doch nicht sein. Also das ist doch Voodoo, oder? Ich meine, die werden doch nicht in ihrer Datenbank stehen haben. Der Kleine, der ist ein Pressetyp. Den müssen wir gut... Weißt du, so was macht man noch nicht.
Also ich würde das tun als Telekom Dienstleister.
Ja, Telekom, zieh dich warm an.
Ja, ich kann vielleicht noch eine Anekdote zur Dämpfung. Und irgendwie DSL geht nicht.
Was ist Dämpfung überhaupt?
Na, du kannst ja DSL nur auf eine bestimmte Länge von Kupferkabeln betreiben. In einer bestimmten Länge ist die Dämpfung des Kupferkabels so groß, dass die Signale nicht ausreichend übertragen werden. Und hier hat uns jemand gemailt, der hatte wohl auch DSL und hat aus Versehen dann mal den Stecker gezogen, irgendwie von dem DSL-Modem. Okay, steckt ihn wieder rein. Dann war irgendwie diese SYNK-Lampe, die da dran ist, rot. Und die ging nicht wieder auf grün. Und daraufhin hat er auch wieder Telekom angerufen. Okay, wir schicken den Techniker vorbei. Der Techniker kam dann auch, hat dann angefangen irgendwie die Leitung durchzumessen und hat dann mit dem Kopf geschüttelt und gesagt, wir hatten schon mal DSL.
Das geht gar nicht.
Hat dann irgendwie noch mal durchgemessen. Und nein, das funktioniert nicht. Sie können kein DSL gehabt haben. Doch, ich hatte DSL. Das ist, also das geht nicht. Da müssen jetzt die Jungs vom Bauabschnitt ran und müssen neue Kabel legen, so. Und dann passierte erst mal eine Weile nichts und daraufhin irgendwie kriegt er dann mal eines Abends einen Anruf und da fragt er, ja, sagen Sie, ist denn die Lampe jetzt noch rot? Und wenn Sie jetzt mal schauen? Ja, jetzt ist die Lampe grün. Okay, danke. Damit war die Sache dann gelaufen. Also das mit dieser Messung, mit der Dämpfung und so.
Wer weiß, wer oder was da zu sehr gedämpft war.
Ja, der Techniker vielleicht.
Oh, wir haben wieder einen. AG, AG, AG, einen haben wir noch. 0331 77 97 110 Telekom-Mitarbeiter oder Mitarbeiter von Telekommunikationsunternehmen. Insbesondere gefragt und natürlich diejenigen von euch, die besonders schöne Geschichten rund um die Deutsche Telekom haben. 0331 77 97 110. Hallo, Frank? Frank, du arbeitest bei der Telekom? Ist Frank dein echter Name?
In dem Falle nicht.
Alles klar. Was machst du da?
Also ich persönlich arbeite bloß bei einer Tochter, aber ich kenne ein bisschen was von dem, was da so rundherum passiert.
Gut, wir lehnen uns zurück und hören dir zu.
Also, zu dem, der da gerade angerufen hat, mit dem Internetcafé 5 Häuser weiter, das kann man nicht vergleichen, weil da zu einem Internetcafé liegt grundsätzlich eine Standleitung und das hat nichts mit dem zu tun, was in den Häusern ankommt. Kann man also nicht vergleichen.
Er hat aber gesagt, dass er die kennt und dass er die gefragt hat, ob die DSL haben.
Das halte ich für ein Internetcafé ein bisschen für ein Gerücht. Ich vermute eher, die haben eine 2-Mit-Standleitung gehabt.
Das hätte ich auch vermutet.
Die Telekom bietet doch auch TDSL Business an, was man auch irgendwie prima als Standleitung benutzen kann.
Ja, das Problem ist ja halt nur, es wird dann immer neu eingestellt, wieder auch bei dem Business. Also mit allem, was es dort gibt, kenne ich mich auch nicht aus. Und das ist das halt. Und zu dieser Dämpfungsmessung kann man einfach nur sagen, diese Messung wird durchgeführt und wenn die bestanden wird, wird garantiert, dass DSL geht. Und wenn die nicht bestanden wird, kann durchaus sein, dass es funktioniert. Klar, es ist aber nur, wenn die Messung bestanden wird, kann man das garantieren, dass es geht. Und das Problem mit dieser DSL-Versorgbarkeit ist einfach nur gewesen, bevor DSL überhaupt erfunden wurde, war Glasfaser gerade modern. Glasfaser war das beste, tollste ISDN-A. Und alle Welt wollte Glasfaser haben.
Alle Welt wollte Glasfaser haben.
Nicht nur bis unten ins Haus, sondern bis in die Wohnung.
Ja, und sobald das Glasfaserkabel da aus der Dose kommt, geht DSL nicht mehr, weil DSL geht nur auf Kupferleitungen.
Das ist klar, aber wenn man die Glasfaser bis in die Wohnung hat, dann braucht man auch kein DSL mehr.
Nee, Glasfaser wird ja momentan nur für ISDN benutzt. Und nicht für DSL. Und wenn ich Internet sehr schnell haben will, brauch ich wieder DSL. Das heißt kein Glasfaser.
Schon klar, aber man könnte ja über die Glasfaser theoretisch das Internet um ein Vielfaches schneller machen als über DSL, wenn man die Glasfaser ausnimmt.
Leider noch nicht, wie so Umsetztechnik, das zu übertragen, das ist ja wieder das Problem.
Also es gibt ausgereifte Glasfasertechnik, dass jetzt irgendwie die Vermittlungsstellen und so nicht mit der Technik ausgestattet sind, das ist schon klar.
Also in Südkorea zum Beispiel ist vielleicht weit weg, aber in Südkorea, da haben sie halt Glasfaser bis in die Wohnung liegen und das funktioniert da prima bei denen.
Ja, bloß wer soll es bezahlen? Die Kunden wollen es alle nicht mehr, weil die Kunden schimpfen auf die Telekom. Die Telekom hat einen Versorgungsauftrag, die muss das bereitstellen, während dem sämtliche Drittanbieter, die irgendwo dazukommen, im Regelfall in die Vermittlungsstellen einen kleinen Schrank reinstellen und damit fertig sind und damit Geld verdienen. Und über die Kabelverlegerei machen die sich keinen Kopf. Und selbst wenn man jetzt irgendwo zu irgendeinem Anbieter geht, es gibt ein paar kleine Regionale, die ein eigenes Netz haben. Aber jetzt hier Mannesmann, Arco oder sowas, die haben in wenigsten Fällen eigenes Netz. Die nutzen alle das Telekom Netz. Und danach, wer das irgendwann mal in die Erde gebuddelt hat, wer die Kosten dafür ausgegeben hat.
Die bezahlen dafür die Gebühren, die wir seit 40 Jahren in der Grundgebühr zahlen, oder?
Das ist richtig, aber es muss ja irgendwo bezahlt werden. Genau über dieselben Gebühren wird ja auch der Ausbau auf Glasfaser bezahlt. Und die Telekom ist ja nicht dafür zuständig, das bis in die Wohnung zu legen. Das ist derjenige zuständig, der die Wohnung vermietet.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Weil die Telekom hat nur irgendwo, eventuell sogar im Haus, eine Anschlussdose und bis da rein. Das ist Sache der Telekom.
Also nochmal auf die Glasfaser zurückzukommen. Wenn meine Informationen so stimmen, ist die Glasfasertechnik am ausgebreitetsten im Osten unseres Landes, sozusagen in den neuen Bundesländern. Vor allen Dingen in Berlin, Friedrichshain und Hohenschenhausen und da gibt es sicherlich noch andere Bezirke. Sogenannt Opalgettos, optischer Anschlussleiter. Und die wurden dann damals in dem tollen Hype, ich weiß nicht wie toll der Hype gewesen ist, aber an meinen Informationen zufolge hat die Telekom damals die Opaltechnik, die damals schon veraltet gewesen ist, in den Ostausbaugebieten sozusagen eingebaut. Und das Problem mit dem DSL ist halt einfach, dass man halt kein DSL auf diesen Opal-Sachen machen kann. Nur, also das stimmt nicht ganz, man kann es machen, aber dazu müsste man die Vermittlungsstellen teuer umrüsten, worauf natürlich die Telekom auch keine Lust hat. Das ist das Problem, da liegt halt Glasfaser und es funktioniert nicht. Jetzt haben wir aber zum Beispiel den Fall, dass im Freedesign die Telekom gerade damit bemüht ist, alle Glasfaserkabeln durch Kupfer zu ersetzen. Das heißt, sie reißen überall die Straßen auf und verlegen neue Kupferleitungen. Das glaube ich nicht, also ich bezweifle.
Es gibt ja, Entschuldigung, wenn ich da jetzt mal reingerätsche, aber es gibt doch gar nichts anderes als DSL. Wenn es was gäbe, wenn mir einer sagen würde, du kriegst jetzt hier zwei MBIT in deine Wohnung, dafür zahlst du von mir aus 100 Euro statt 50 Euro im Monat, dann würde ich dir sagen, gib her und danke. Aber es gibt das Angebot ja gar nicht. Von daher ist schwer zu sagen, die Kunden wollen DSL. Die kriegen ja gar nichts anderes. Also wenn ich nur ein Trabant kaufen kann, da brauch ich mich auch nicht nach einem Ford zu sehen.
Wenn es denn mit dem DSL funktioniert, könnte man ja jetzt auch dieses 1500 dabeustellen. Das läuft auch nur sehr schleppend an. Das ist im Prinzip eigentlich so eine Nullnummer geworden.
Naja, das ist aber ganz einfach eine Nullnummer geworden, was da keine Flett-Tarife gibt. Die Leute wollen Flett haben, sie wollen keine Treffig-Abrechnung. Also der normale Mensch will das halt einfach nicht.
Und das ist aber dann auch wieder die Frage, eine reine Flett funktioniert nur, wenn eine Mischkalkulation funktioniert. Wenn alle Welt dranhängt und saugt sie die Blöden, funktioniert das auch nicht mehr. Dann muss eine Treffig-Abrechnung her. Ansonsten rechnet sich nicht mehr. Und wenn sich nicht rechnet, macht kein Unternehmen das mit. Das kann auch die Telekom nicht auf die Dauer finanzieren.
Ja, natürlich nicht.
Also müssen sie sich was einfallen lassen.
Aber es wäre ja ein leichtes, eine Mischkalkulation auch mit vernünftigen Trafikpreisen aufzuziehen. Das würde ja gehen.
Das ist dann noch die Frage. Aber da sind wir wieder bei dem Versorgungsauftrag. Die Telekom muss auch in den letzten Winkel der Republik eine Telefonzelle stellen. Ein Drittanbieter, der sucht sich irgendwo ein Sahnestück, irgendeine Passage und sagt, hey super, bei uns könnt ihr für 5 Cent die Minute an der Telefonzelle telefonieren. Das kann die Telekom nicht ringen, weil die muss ja auch eine Telefonzelle an der Stelle aufstellen, wo alle 10 Jahre ein Kunde vorbeikommt und eine halbe Minute Notruf absetzen will. Die Telefonzelle muss da stehen. Das sieht der Gesetzgeber so vor. Das ist so vereinbart. Das muss die Telekom machen. Das muss ein Drittanbieter, der irgendwo sitzt, nicht machen. Und das sind alles Sachen, die finanziert werden müssen.
Ja, aber ich meine, dafür haben sie jetzt Ausgleich halt einfach mal das quasi Monopol auf die Letzte Meile.
Auch das fällt.
Ja, das heißt es seit 10 Jahren. Also das warte ich ja noch drauf.
Ja, weil keiner bereit ist, das zu übernehmen.
Was zu übernehmen?
Die Letzte Meile.
Ja, naja.
Weil die Letzte Meile heißt dann nämlich Tatsache, dass diese vielen Millionen Drehzins in die Wohnung reingehen. Und die müssen erstmal gelegt werden.
Na gut, plus da ist es ja tatsächlich, so wie Holger auch schon gesagt hat, das wurde ja quasi 40 Jahre lang von unseren Steuergeldern bezahlt. Als es halt noch die Post war und das alles gelegt wurde, da wurde das ja sozusagen, da war das ja noch staatlich. Das ist ja quasi alles schon mal gemacht worden und bezahlt worden.
Ja, nur für die schon angesprochene Technik reicht es halt nicht mehr. Das heißt, es muss neu gemacht werden. Und das neu machen will auch keiner bezahlen, aber alle brüllen sich, sie wollen wenigstens DSL haben, wenn sie schon nicht Glasfaser kriegen können. Ja, wenn ich aber außerhalb dieser besagten Zone wohne, wo es mir garantiert wird, dass ich das bekommen kann. Deswegen gibt es ja jetzt auch bloß dieses DSL Lite. Das DSL Lite ist nichts anderes. Es ist nur diese garantierte Mindestgeschwindigkeit wurde runtergesetzt, damit ich einfach weiter weg noch einen Anschluss legen kann.
Was ist Lite?
Was macht das?
Das hat eine geringere garantierte Übertragungsrate. Kostet aber das gleiche. Wenn du weiter weg bist von der Vermittlungsstelle, dass sie das trotzdem schalten. Aber deine Übertragungsrate ist glaube ich die Hälfte.
Habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen, das Angebot. Bieten sie dir das nur an, wenn du außerhalb wohnst und es bestellst?
Das wird halt nicht offensiv vermarktet. Das ist halt bloß auf Nachfrage entstanden.
Die Kunden wollen diese Technik haben und beschweren sich, dass es nicht geht. Aber wenn man jetzt sagt, man bietet mit 768 an, dann wird eigentlich der Telekom schon fast wieder in Stricke dreht, wenn nur 700 rauskommen. Und das ist aber auch wieder so ein Trickschluss.
Naja, den Ball kann man jederzeit wieder zurückspielen, Frank. Wenn ich einen Fernseher einschalte und ich schalte bundesweit empfangbare Programme ein, sogar europaweit empfangbare Programme, sehe ich da eine fürchterlich animierte Plastikfigur namens Robert T. Online und eine ehemalige Fernsehmoderatorin namens Enifante Maiklokjes, die jedem einzelnen Bundesbürger erzählen, dass es DSL gibt. Ich mein, wer so wirbt, der darf sich nicht wundern, dass die Konsumenten sagen, ja dann gib auch her. Und wenn du nicht liefern kannst, dann ist es dein Problem. Und wir werden dich in der Luft zerreißen. Also ich finde nicht, dass die Telekom da unschuldig ist.
Das habe ich auch nicht so behauptet. Nur sie wird halt immer als die Alleinschuldigen hingestellt. Aber der Markt hat halt diese Glasfaser abgefragt. Überall sollte Glasfaser eingebaut werden, unbedingt.
Das bezweifle ich halt immer noch.
Weil auf Glasfaser halt so noch nicht funktioniert hat. Denn gab es DSL. Alle Welt wollte DSL haben. Da konnten nur Schultern gezuckt werden, weil es hieß, es geht nur auf Kupfer. Und sie wollten Glasfaser haben, jetzt haben sie Glasfaser.
Wer hat denn da das Glasfaser gewollt?
Sonst wäre es doch so nicht eingebaut worden.
Na ja, Entscheidungen wären nicht immer so getroffen. Niemand von den Kunden hat gesagt, ich möchte Glasfaser.
Es war die Entwicklung der Zeit, da Glasfaser einzusetzen.
Nein, das war veraltete Technik, irgendwo in Wohngebiete einzubauen. Das ist keine Entwicklung der Zeit.
Na gut, damals war Glasfaser der große Hype. Man hat gesagt, überall muss Glasfaser hin. Was im Prinzip gar nicht so verkehrt ist. Aber was die doofe Sache ist, ist, dass eine Weile später plötzlich festgestellt wurde, eigentlich können wir mehr als 14, 4 oder so etwas über Kupferkabel machen. Dann hieß es plötzlich, jetzt ist DSL der große Hype. Keiner hat sich mehr für die Glasfaser interessiert. Das wurde nicht weiterverfolgt. Das ist das eigentlich Tragische, dass die Glasfasersache komplett fallen gelassen wurde und nicht weiterverfolgt wurde. Im Prinzip ist das ja das, was wir im Endeffekt alle mal haben wollen, nämlich Glasfaser in der Wohnung oder zumindest unten im Haus liegen.
Das ist noch die Frage.
Das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann wieder eine Entwicklung dahingeben.
Ich denke auch mal.
Dann ist wieder die Frage, wie lange dauert das bis dahin? Weil die Gelder zur Forschung in irgendwas müssen ja auch erst da sein. Dann hat irgendwann einer herausgefunden, wie das funktionieren soll mit der Übertragungstechnik und alles pipa pro. Und bis dahin, weil es jetzt vielleicht nicht noch 5 Jahre dauert, sondern noch 10 Jahre, sind sämtliche Glasfaserleitungen wieder rausgerissen worden. Sollte es die Telekom AG Konzern noch geben, die haben sich Mühe gegeben. Alle Welt hat Kupfer, alle Welt hat DSL. Jetzt heißt es plötzlich, alles super, wir haben wieder Glasfaser. Glasfaser ist wesentlich besser. Wir schaffen jetzt nicht mehr, was weiß ich, 1, 5 Megabit, sondern wir können euch garantieren 10 Megabit sofort ohne Probleme. Dann rennt wieder alle Welt nach Glasfaser. Dann heißt es auf einmal wieder böse Telekom. Warum hast du vor 5 Jahren die Glasfaserkabel wieder rausgesessen?
Ich denke, dafür wird sich in der nächsten Zeit eine Lösung geben. Sie sind jetzt halt dabei, Standard zu spezifizieren, um Ethernet über 2 Drahtkupfer addern zu machen. Ich denke mal, das wird dann das DSL irgendwann ablösen.
Das bleibt dann zu hoffen. Die Frage ist halt nur wieder auch, wie weit funktioniert die Technik? Das ist ja bei dem DSL nichts anderes. Es wurde die Zahl genannt, 768, die funktioniert so weit. Also wäre die Telekom doch schön blöd zu sagen, wir legen es auch weiter. Dann können sie es so nicht mehr garantieren. Also lassen sie es lieber bleiben. Das ist, um mal eine Zahl zu sagen, was weiß ich, 500 Meter rum funktioniert es. Es gibt auch Stellen, Kabel gerade ziemlich direkt verlegt, da ist es dann 550 Meter weg und es funktioniert immer noch. Bei manchen vielleicht sogar 600 Meter. Und an anderen Stellen haben sie vielleicht mit 480 Meter zu kämpfen, dass sie noch rankriegen. Irgendwo muss man eine Grenze ziehen. Um dann zu sagen, pass auf, du wohnst 550 Meter weg, ich kann es dir nicht garantieren, aus Barstahl ist es nicht verfügbar.
Aber ich meine, da könnte man das doch machen. Ich kenne so viele Leute, die genau dieses Problem haben, dass sie zu weit weg wohnen, die sagen, ist mir scheißegal, ich nehme es ohne Garantie, dann ist es langsamer, ich würde es bloß gerne nehmen. Und die Telekom legt es trotzdem nicht, sagt, wir können das nicht garantieren, statt dass es da, ich meine, es gibt jetzt diese Leitvariante, aber statt dass es einfach legen, den Kunden unterschreiben lassen, wir garantieren für überhaupt gar nichts, ist es auf eigenes Risiko des Kunden oder ist es ihm dann halt trotzdem legen?
Ja, da ist dann wieder die Frage, das muss im Prinzip die obere Leitungsebene entscheiden, also da bin ich viel zu weit entfernt davon, um da irgendwas zu sagen, warum das nicht gemacht wird. Weil ich halt, wie gesagt, auch nicht direkt beim Rosa-Riesen arbeite, sondern nur bei einem Ableger. Aber es ist halt, Entscheidungen brauchen in so einem Konzern seine Zeit, die brauchen auch bei Mercedes seine Zeit. Da fragt ja auch keiner nach, wie lange die gebraucht haben, um ein neues L rauszubringen oder so. Das interessiert ja keinen.
Ja, aber wenn wir ein harisches kriegen, repariert. Und zwar auf Anhieb von jemandem Kompetentem.
Da wäre ich mir auch immer nicht unbedingt so richtig. Ja, ja, ja. Wobei Stern drauf ist, ist jeder Werkstatt-Monteur irgendwo gleich kompetent.
Zumindest vermittelt er mir den Eindruck, dass er es ist.
Na gut, das hatten wir ja schon.
Ich denke mal, das wird bei uns im Konzern auch durchaus versucht, wenigstens zu vermitteln, dass wir kompetent sind. Ob wir das denn für den Fall immer wirklich sind, ist eine andere Frage. Aber das ist auch eine Sache, die man kann alles wissen. Und der Monteur, der da irgendwo auftaucht, der wird bei dem einen für DSL-Messungen, bei dem nächsten soll er einen Analogmodem entstören, bei dem dritten ein ISDN-Kabel schwenken und bei dem vierten eine Standleitung machen. Und das dann alles innerhalb von drei Stunden oder sowas. Ich meine irgendwo.
Spezialisierung.
Spezialisierung ist Sache der Insekten. Frank, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Hast dich gut geschlagen. Und gute Nacht. Null Uhr 6 war das Chaos Radio. Und zwar Nummer 83, Abenteuer, Letzte Meile ist unser Thema. Falls irgendjemand von euch Geneigten Höhrenden jetzt noch nicht wütend ist, können wir dieses Lied gerne wiederholen. Thorsten, was war das? The Exploited. The Exploited, natürlich. Das hätte ich auch von selber drauf kommen können. Steht jetzt schließlich auf dem Zettel. 0331 77 91 10 ist die Nummer der Fritzotlein. Die müsst ihr anrufen, wenn ihr Abenteuer mit der Letzten Meile, also sprich Abenteuer mit der Deutschen Telekom, euer eigenen beziehungsweise zum Besten geben wollt. Und zwar die schönsten und wildesten Abenteuer, die ihr je mit der Deutschen Telekom erlebt habt. 0331 77 91 10, natürlich interessieren uns auch alle anderen Telefon, an Telefon, Dienstanbieter, also Berlikom, ACOR, wie sie alle heißen und Erfahrung mit Berlikom. Die hat die Linda, hallo Linda.
Hallo Linda. Ja. Also der Glasfaser-Diskussion kann ich mich jetzt nicht mehr anschließen, aber wie gesagt, es geht um Berlikom. Weil ich hab mal nachgeguckt, ihr sitzt ja in Potsdam, ne? Und Berlikom legt da auch Anschlüsse und wir hatten uns, weil wir auch ziemlich angeschissen waren von der Telekom, einfach mal für Berlikom interessiert und da glaub ich 2.000 hier in Anschluss legen lassen. Und da meinten die auch, es dauert etwas, weil die halt so neu waren in Berlin und von wegen Anschluss legen. Aber es ging dann halt doch recht schnell, also ich würde sagen maximal ein Vierteljahr. Und dann hatten wir unsere Analogleitung erst mal fürs Telefon. Und dann ging noch alles reibungslos. Ich glaub, da kam auch so ein Monteur und hat das uns alle vorangemacht bei mir im Zimmer. Und irgendwann kam halt auch die Internetsache. Und ich hab's meinem Papa gesagt, also ich möchte gerne Flatrate haben. Weil wir bezahlen 30 Euro dafür im Monat ISDN. Und können halt so viel ins Internet wie wir wollen. Und bei der Berlikom ist halt der Vorteil, dass sie vielleicht ziemlich teure Tarife haben, auch was DSL angeht. Aber du kannst halt, sag ich mal, auf Tochterunternehmen wechseln, beziehungsweise auf Firmen, die mit Berlikom kooperieren. Und das wäre dann einmal Surfnet, wo wir jetzt unseren Tarif herbeziehen. Und die haben, wie gesagt, eine Flatrate für ISDN für 30 Euro. Und wir haben halt zwei Leitungshause. Und ja, ist eben ganz praktisch. Und weil ihr so erzählt habt, Arkors-Scheiße, weiß ich auch von einer Freundin, dass Arkors-Scheiße ist, Telekom ist Scheiße, na dann könnt ihr eigentlich nur bei Berlikom mal fragen.
Du bist der erste Mensch, den ich kennenlerne, also jetzt zumindest quasi kennenlerne, der sagt, Berlikom ist super. Alle anderen sagen, ey Berlikom, geh mir weg. Ja.
Ich muss sagen, ich hab auch viel Schlechtes von Berlikom gehört.
Hab ich auch, aber ich hab selber auch was mit Berlikom zu tun gehabt und war da eigentlich auch positiv überrascht. Da war ich ja beim Geschäftskunden.
Der Analyst kann natürlich nicht davon reden, weil wir sind ja nur Privatkunden, aber auch, wenn wir da mal angerufen hatten irgendwie in so einem Callcenter und Kunden-Service, dann wussten ja ich auch immer weiter. Also die sind da glaube ich ein bisschen besser organisiert als die Telekom.
Mich haben die auch sogar angerufen. Ihre Leitung ist gerade da und was? Sollen wir sie wieder ganz machen?
Wenn sie kurz Zeit hätten.
Nicht schlecht. Ja Linda, das bringt uns jetzt natürlich völlig aus dem Konzept hier, ne? Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tschau. Gut, mal gucken ob der nächste Christian, Christian, hast du mit Berlikom gute Erfahrungen gemacht?
Ich habe mit Berlikom sehr gute Erfahrungen.
Tschüss Christian.
Erzähl mal.
Ja und zwar wohne ich in Treptow, ne Treptow Park und die Berlikom hat schon seit Jahren erzählt, hier gibt es kein ISDN.
Geht nicht, gibt es nicht.
Ende von Miet.
Wie kein ISDN geht es überhaupt? Geht kein ISDN?
ISDN haben sie gekriegt, aber halt kein DSL. Ja und darauf haben wir gesagt, schnauze voll, DSL sollten sein. Weil wir wollten auch ein Flat-Raid haben. Man guckt, der Leekom sieht nicht schlecht aus. DSL bestellt er, kein Problem, auch gekriegt.
Auch glaube ich ein Vierteljahr gewartet.
Das hat keine 20 Minuten gedauert. Und dann war alles hier installiert, alles fertig. Und diese tolle Techniker von der Telekom stellen erst mal fest, dass dieser NTBA von der Telekom die ganzen Jahre kaputt war. Also war vorher einfach ein kaputtes Telekomgerät drin. Und ich hab mit DSL keinen Absturz gehabt, kein gar nix seit ich Bellikopf hab. Keine Probleme. Ja, und dass es DSL noch nicht so lange gibt, das ist eine Lüge. Wir haben in der Schule mit 94 angefangen, damit zu arbeiten.
Ja, die DSL-Technik ist wesentlich älter.
Die große Vermarktung ist erst vor ein paar Jahren losgegangen.
Ja, die ist vor ein paar Jahren losgegangen. Aber mit L haben die schon ein paar Jahre und die wussten, dass es eigentlich auch funktioniert. Also ich hätt das vorher viel früher einführen können und ich bin der Meinung, sie können es auch überall hinschmeißen.
Überall hinschmeißen können sie es nicht. Die Erfahrungen haben gezeigt, dass sie nicht überall hinwerfen können und dass es pro Problemus funktioniert, ist halt auch immer eine Frage der Technik dazwischen. Das ist schon richtig.
Und die Kompetenz der Mitarbeiter. Ich hab einen Telekom-Mitarbeiter erwischt, der wollte mir ein Münztelefon für ein Kartentelefon verkaufen.
Ja, schnibbeln sie die klein und werfen sie sie da rein.
Genau, sie kennen doch diese kleinen, runden, schweren Karten.
Ich hatte mich bei der Telekom beschwert zu dem Thema, weil dieser Automat gab mir kein Wechselgeld.
Wie jetzt, das Kartentelefon?
Ich hab das letzte Mal im Jahr 1999 mit einem Münztelefon telefoniert und da gaben die noch Wechselgeld.
Und das machen die nicht mehr?
Die haben einen falschen Aufgeber drauf geklopft. Und die waren echt der Meinung, ich würde in einem Kartentelefon gehen.
Und Münzer geben kein Wechselgeld raus?
Und dann immer auch noch die Technik. Ich hab selbst mit der Technik gesprochen, die waren auch der Meinung, ich stehe in einem Kartentelefon.
Mein Fehler an der Datenbank.
Geben Münz-Fernsprecher kein Wechselgeld?
Seit der Euro-Umstellung geben sie dies nicht mehr. Und das steht auch normalerweise wohl auf diesen Aufklebern drauf, die sie über reingeklebt haben. Bloß ich hab ein Münz-Telefon erwischt, da war der Aufkleber eines Kartentelefons drin.
Und war es eine gelbe Telefonzelle?
Nein, es war keine gelbe mehr. Es war schon eine von diesen neuen.
Gibt es überhaupt noch Gelbe, außer bei meinem Freund Ron im Badezimmer als Dusche?
Im Kreuzberg steht wohl noch einer irgendwie. An der Oranienstraße, da steht vor so einem Kino, da steht noch einer. Stimmt, klar.
Da steht noch so eine gelbe.
Ansonsten haben sie ja immer diese komischen Säulen da, wo sich dann die Leute beschwert haben, dass man da immer im Regen steht beim Telefonieren. Und irgendwie der Verkehr...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, der Regen ist ja gar nicht so problematisch, aber das sind ja nur Hauptverkehrsstraße.
Du hörst nichts und daraufhin haben sie dann halt angefangen, da noch Glaswände an die Seite zu machen und ein bisschen Dach oben drauf und so ein Kram.
Kann man besser kaputt schlagen. Nothammer aus dem Bus.
Also die gelben alten Telefonzellen waren immer noch. Also die waren schick.
Diese neuen Zellen bringen sehr viel, vor allen Dingen an der Frankfurter Allee.
Ja, an der Frankfurter Allee. Super.
Jouet, Christian, vielen Dank. Und eine gute Nacht noch. Gut, letzte Telco außerhalb. Uwe.
Ja, hallo.
Endlich mal. Ja, Acor von wegen. Sagen wir mal so. Erstmal wollte ich was sagen zu der... Bin ich eigentlich zu laut? Ich mach mal leise hier.
Sprich du lieber zu laut, bevor du zu leise bist.
Ich hab mich im Radio gehört. Erstmal zu der Frau, die vorhin angerufen hat, damals sag ich schon. Von wegen mit ihrem Abrechnungsproblem. Ich hab da was drüber gelesen letztens.
Kurz für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben. Freenet in Casso hat die Telekom gemacht. Das Geld wurde an die Telekom bezahlt. Die Telekom hat das Geld aber nicht an Freenet weitergegeben. Und jetzt mahnt Freenet den Kunden, obwohl der Kunde das Geld der Telekom bereits gegeben hat.
Ja, jetzt ist die Sache, was ich gelesen hab, war, dass die Telekom dazu übergegangen ist, oder beziehungsweise festgelegt hat, dass sie zwar die Beträge auf der Rechnung ausweisen, aber für die Mahnung, was sich irgendwie nach bürgerlichem Gesetzbuch auch ganz okay anhört, für die Mahnung der Freenet AG nicht haften. Dann hat also vielleicht auch Freenet nicht gemahnt, der Betrag wurde vielleicht auch tatsächlich nicht richtig in Rechnung gestellt, oder vielleicht doch übersehen, weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls, die Telekom stellt keine Mahnung für andere Unternehmen.
Nee, das ist richtig, sie stellen keine Mahnung für andere Unternehmen, aber...
Das kann aber kommen, dass man, wenn man keine Mahnung bekommt, und Freenet das auch versäumt haben sollte, weil sie es ja über die Telekom einziehen, dass man zwei Jahre später darauf hingewiesen wird, dass man die Rechnung aufzubewahren hat. Sowas kann natürlich mal passieren. Ich weiß nicht, wie das genau jetzt aussieht, aber das war die grundlegende Aussage. Die mahnen nicht und stellen auch keinen Euro Mahngebühr aus für andere Anbieter.
Sollte man vielleicht noch mal klären, wie lange überhaupt solche Sachen nachberechnet werden können.
Jetzt tu nicht so, wir haben das geklärt. Wir haben nämlich ein Interview aufgezeichnet mit einem Rechtsanwalter. Das werden wir im Laufe der restlichen Sendung noch zu Gehör bringen. Na gut, wir brauchen doch jetzt nicht so zu tun.
Jetzt habe ich mir sowas tolles überlegt Holger.
Ich wollte eine goldene Brücke bauen.
Das war plötzlich mein Problem.
Scheitern auf hohem Niveau jetzt. Aber wir haben hier inzwischen auch noch eine Mail gekriegt zu dieser Freenet-Geschichte. Da hatte auch jemand das Problem mit der Telekom und Freenet. Und das war genauso wie Anke das vorhin auch erzählt hatte, dass sie halt an die Telekom Geld bezahlt haben und Freenet sich dann irgendwann gemeldet hat. Und da war es dann allerdings so, dass derjenige bei der Telekom und bei Freenet angerufen hat und die haben das dann irgendwie untereinander geklärt gekriegt. Und das war überhaupt kein Problem. Vielleicht war das Problem jetzt bei Anke, dass es halt tatsächlich schon zwei Jahre zurück lag. Aber ja, offensichtlich, also manchmal scheint es auch zu funktionieren.
Also ich wollte mal sagen, es war folgendes. Ich hab noch in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg gewohnt vor etwas über einem Jahr. Hab mir damals aufgrund des billigeren Angebotes auch von AQOR einen DSL-Anschluss bestellt. Die haben gesagt, DSL ist noch nicht lieferbar. Ich hab mich auch gewundert, dass es eigentlich für ISDN alles relativ schnell ging. Die haben mir gesagt, das kommt irgendwann. Und dann hab ich auf der Rechnung immer gesehen, dass da DSL 128 stand. Das war dieser nette Tarif. Ich dachte erst, die verarschen mich. Ich hab noch kein DSL. Das war einfach eine Kanalbündelung, aber für den Preis einer ISDN. Irgendwie haben sie daraus eine günstigere Flatrate, aber schneller auf 128 Kilobit-Basis gemacht.
Davon hab ich auch mal gehört.
Das hab ich dann auch im Kopf behalten, weil ich bin umgezogen, hab mich bei denen auf der Suchmaschine auf ihrer Homepage umgeguckt. Als ich mir die Wohnung schon ausgesucht hab, ja, wir können an dieser Wohnung, also ich bin jetzt hier in Mitte, können wir ihnen ISDN und DSL liefern. Als ich umgezogen war, ich hab denen Fax geschickt, betreffend Umzug und wann und wie und was, und hab eigentlich drauf gewartet, dass sie mich da mal anschreiben. Hab dann zwar eine Rechnung nochmal gekriegt über die Grundgebühr, hab aber nichts gehört. Hab dann nochmal ein Wochen später angerufen und da hat diese Frau, die dann im OP-Center da vor dem Rechner saß, mir dann mit Entsetzen mitgeteilt, ja, das ist Opal, da können wir ihnen kein DSR liefern, meine ich. Ja, aber dann hätten sie ja, ich hatte ja vorher auch keins. Hätten sie mir wenigstens mal ISDN. Nee, das können wir bei der Telekom, wir kommen nicht ran.
Ja, im Opal-Gedruck kann auch AGOR kein ISDN liefern.
Also haben sie aber behauptet, dass sie das kann?
Ja, ja, sie haben viel behauptet.
Ja, wie, jetzt aus rechtlichen oder aus technischen Gründen?
Nein, aus technischen Gründen null.
Ja, aber sie behaupten, dass es trotzdem geht.
Ja, eigentlich ist das kriminell.
Und dann meldest du dich dann nämlich an und musst auch mit deinem gesamten Anschluss darüber. Und wenn du das gemacht hast, dann kriegst du dich nicht mehr richtig abgemeldet.
Na ja, jedenfalls wollen die jetzt von mir nichts mehr. Auf jeden Fall bin ich dann zur Telekom in den T-Punkt gegangen. Und da gab es dann halt gerade die Umstellung mit diesen Modems, dass die Geld kosten sollten. Und ich hab nochmal so ein Schnäppchen mit gemacht, wo ich dann irgendwie nur 29 Euro dafür bezahlt hätte. Hab das natürlich genommen. Die haben mir auch gesagt, es kann dauern. Da wusste ich noch nichts von Opal übrigens. Dann war mir das mit dem Opal klar. Und dann kam aber auch wirklich irgendwann der Techniker. Und ich muss sagen, ich fühlte mich von dem gut beraten. Weil ich hab mit dem ein bisschen gelabert. Der hat seine Messarbeiten durchgeführt. Also es ging jetzt um ISDN. Und da meint sie, ja, im T-Punkt haben sie natürlich versprochen, spätestens im halben Jahr habe ich nichts drauf gegeben. Und mit ihm habe ich ein bisschen länger unterhalten. Und der hat mir das auch so dargestellt. Also er meinte, das ist eine Sache. Also entweder müsste man die Straße komplett aufreißen und halt einen Kupferkabel zumindest parallel legen. Das machen die aber nicht für einen einzelnen Kunden. Was mir auch klar ist, aber er meinte für so eine Vermittlungsstelle, um die dann auch auszustatten, also das kostet ein paar Millionen.
Wenn sie Kupfer reinlegen.
Ja, also auch das in der Vermittlung dann umzustellen. Kupferkabel, Baugenehmigung und bla bla bla. So und wenn irgendwann mal da Arbeiten vorgenommen werden, machen sie das vielleicht. Das ist die Frage dann pro Verteiler, vielleicht 10.000 Haushalte sollten da dran sein. Ich habe gesagt, ich würde ja freiwillig in meiner Nachbarschaft Handzettel austragen, um DSL-Werbung zu machen, wenn sie mir dann sagen, na gut. Und die Sache ist, ich habe jetzt halt hier ein Modem bezahlt, was ich nicht benutzen kann. Ich ziehe nächstes Jahr Ende des Jahres wieder aus aus dieser Wohnung, weil der Mietvertrag befristet. Ich habe es eigentlich schon ausgegeben. Bloß dann meine ODIFAY war eigentlich, dass ich dann bei der Telekom angerufen habe. Er hat gesagt, na probieren sie es mal. Immer nerven. Immer nerven die Leute. Und sich durchfragen. Okay, ich habe dann auch aus Rechnungsgründen und so habe mich dann durchgefragt. Ich habe jetzt mittlerweile hier einen Wust von 800er und 180er Nummern, die ich anrufen kann. Also die Kundennummer von der Telekom ist dieselbe wie von T-Online.
Nee, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Firmen.
Ja, aber die eine...
Nein, nein, nein, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Firmen.
Ja, ja, aber ich habe nur eine Service-Nummer.
Wir haben mit der Telekom nichts zu tun.
Wir müssten ja trotzdem, wenn ich dieselbe Nummer habe, bei beiden Firmen diese Nummer vorhanden sein.
Nein, nein, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Firmen.
Es ist in der Tat so.
Das ist doch alles so ein verbrecherisches Pack.
Man kommt in welchen Callsend daraus.
Das ist wichtig.
Ich habe halt nach bürgerlichem Gesetzbuch gesagt. So leben wir halt. Und die andere Sache war, ich hab dann halt mal da vorsichtig angehört, hab gemeint, was mich genervt hat, war, dass ich halt keine Flatrate kriege. Weil DSL, also ich bin jetzt nicht da, der große, was weiß ich, MP3-Sauger, oder was weiß ich, was auch immer.
Wir auch nicht.
Aber meine Onlinezeit möchte ich gerne, am liebsten 24 Stunden haben, auch wenn es länger dauert.
Du willst eine garantierte vorhandene Verbindung, die muss nicht breitbandig sein, sondern sie muss da sein, wenn du sie brauchst. Du willst, dass du dir keine Gedanken darüber machen musst, wie lange du gerade richtig liegen zurfst.
Ja, und das kostet dann ja auch. Die Sache war, dass ich diese Technik von ARKOR mal erwähnt habe, und habe gesagt, ich habe dieses Stichwort DSL-Lite. So etwas gab es doch bei ARKOR auch. Das nannte sich bei denen DSL-128. Und dann meinte die Erste, und da ist ein Steinturm Herz und Zahn, die meinte, ja, so etwas gibt es aber nur, wenn man nicht im normalen Versorgungsbereich ist, wo man ein normales DSL kriegen kann. Und dann kam es bei mir schon so in Hoffnung auf. Und sie meinten dann auch, sie schicken mir dazu was zu. Ich werde angerufen oder kriege einen Brief. Habe ich aber bis jetzt nichts gekriegt. Ist auch schon drei Monate her. Ich habe dann weiter telefoniert. Die nächste Tante wusste dann gar nicht. Also die waren alle sehr freundlich. Die nächste Tante, ich übrigens auch, die nächste Tante wusste davon gar nichts. Sie hat mich dann zur Technik weiter verbunden. Und da war dann ein Mann dran. Und der hat mich auf dieses Ding, auf diese Nachfrage nach ISDN, DSL-Leit hier. Davon hat er noch nie gehört, wenn mir den Scheiß erzählt hat. Also ich habe ihm dann gesagt, Entschuldigung, ich bin Netzwerk-Techniker, ich bin kein Otto-Normal-dummer-User oder so. Ja, was erzählen Sie mir denn hier überhaupt? Können Sie mir mal bitte sagen, welche Kollegin das war? Habe ich ihm natürlich nicht gesagt. Nachher kriegt die arme Frau noch Ärger. Aber jedenfalls wüsste ich eigentlich gerne mal, wie ist das mit dem DSL-Leiter? Also ich bin hier technisch von einer Flatrate ausgeschlossen sozusagen. Ich kriege weder DSL, ich kriege nur, also maximal für einen teuren Preis 120 Stunden im Monat.
Also das ist, dieses DSL 128 bei Arcore, das war ja überhaupt gar kein DSL, sondern das war halt tatsächlich Kanalbündelung über ISDN.
Ist mir aber egal wie.
Ja, genau. So während jetzt dieses DSL-Lite bei der Telekom, das gibt es tatsächlich inzwischen, kostet das gleiche wie normales DSL und ist auch DSL. Also das geht nicht über Kanalbündelung, sondern das hat immer noch die halbe Bandbreite. Also ich glaube, die garantieren ja 384 Kbps. Und das ist tatsächliches DSL. Das heißt, damit können sie es dir ins Opal-Ghetto auch einfach mal nicht legen. Allerdings ist es so...
Können Sie machen, wollen Sie aber natürlich nicht tun, weil es halt Geld kostet. Und das, was AQUA damals getan hat, nämlich dieses 128er DSL, da haben sie auch ordentlich Schotter an die Telekom bezahlt, um den Leuten das zu geben. Und ich erinnere mich dunkel, dass es da irgendeinen Prozess zugegeben hat. Genau deswegen, weil AQUA einem DSL versprochen hat, dass es nicht liefern konnte. Und ich glaube, sie wurden dann gezwungen, sowas zu tun. Aber sie haben es dann selber getan, um ihren guten Namen zu retten.
Ja, also ich müsste jetzt quasi ein Flat-Rad-Provider für ISDN, aber im Opal-Ghetto gibt es keinen anderen Anbieter, oder wie sehe ich das?
Es gibt im Opal-Ghetto definitiv keinen DSF.
Allerdings ist es so, dass in Friedrichshain die Telekom tatsächlich gerade dabei ist, die Straßen aufzureißen und Kupferkabel zu legen, dahin, wo bisher nur Glasfaser liegt.
Genau, ansonsten kannst du dich auch gerne noch an meinen WLAN mit dranhängen, wenn du bei mir neben mir wohnst.
Bei mir wird gerade von Verdi das Hauptquartier um die Ecke gebaut. Vielleicht soll ich dann mal bei dem Bauleiter fragen, wann die denn da mal irgendwie eine Kabelschacht aufreißen, um dann den Telekom-Marketingverantwortlichen Berlin anzurufen.
Bei der Telekom ist es tatsächlich so, sie verlegen nach und nach wieder Kupferkabel, da wo bisher nur Glasfaser liegt, und sie gehen danach da, wo die Leute am meisten schreien. Da wird es am ehesten gemacht. Deshalb bringt es da tatsächlich Sinn, häufig nachzufragen. Wenn da auch verschiedene Leute nachfragen und Aufträge für DSL geben und so Geschichten, wurde mir zumindest gesagt, dass es dann schneller geht.
Gut, aber was jetzt meine Frage war, angeblich dürfen sie aus rechtlichen Gründen, aus Wettbewerbsgründen, mir aber wiederum, seltsamer Wettbewerb, dürfen sie mir aber laut Gerichtsurteil keine Flatrate anbieten. Auch nicht, wenn ich sie anderweitig nicht erhalten könnte. Und die Frage war jetzt, ist es wirklich so, dass über Opal, so hat sich ja AQOR damals rausgerätet, da hat natürlich der Techniker gesagt, das ist eine Ausrede von AQOR, die könnten ihnen schon ISDN bieten. Du hast jetzt vorhin gesagt, über Opal geht es nicht. Also AQOR kann über Opal nicht liefern, aus technischen Gründen. Also kann das eigentlich auch kein anderer, nämlich mal, oder? Könnte das Berlin kommen?
Also soweit ich weiß, bietet kein Anbieter in Berlin an, außer der Telekom, dir über Opal ISDN zu legen. Also das kann tatsächlich nur die Telekom. Aber dass sie die Telekom aus wettbewerbsrechtlichen Gründen da keine Flatrate anbieten darf, das ist Blödsinn.
Das ist verständlich nach dem Gleichheitsprinzip sozusagen. Wenn kein anderer Anbieter dir in einem Opal-Ghetto ISDN-Flatrates liefern kann, dann darf die Telekom das auch nicht tun, weil sie dadurch sozusagen ein Monopol ausnutzen würde.
Im Endeffekt ist die freie Marktwirtschaft so, dass ich es überhaupt nicht kriegen kann.
Internet ist doch nicht reguliert.
Na ja, dann ist ja sozusagen ISDN. Es geht ja da erstmal nicht um Internet, sondern es geht um ISDN.
Also ich wollte jetzt auch nochmal zu dem Glasfaser was sagen, und zwar zu dieser Entwicklung. Also wenn man dazu jetzt mal, da kommt mal irgendwie erst mal, was der eine Anrufer vorhin gesagt hat. Das ist eine ökonomische Frage. Da kann ich jetzt auf die Telekom schimpfen, also wer nun die Steuern bezahlt hat oder nicht. Ich muss mal sagen, die Leute sind gehypt worden. Die Leute haben auch geglaubt an die schöne neue Informationswelt, haben auch ihre Aktien gekauft, haben auch geglaubt, dass sie noch über 200 oder 500% hinaus immer noch die Aktie steigt, auch wenn es seit einem halben Jahr fällt. Also die Leute müssen auch mal bei ihrer eigenen Blödheit anfangen.
Ja gut, jetzt vermischst du aber gerade Äpfel mit Birnen. Also ob jetzt die Telekom über alle technischen Probleme, die es offensichtlich mit ihr gibt, auch noch klein anlegerwillentlich abgezockt hat, ist ja eine ganz andere Geschichte. Das Ding ist ganz einfach mal, dass wir seit Jahrzehnten Grundgebühr für Leitungen zahlen, die einfach so in die Erde verbuddelt sind. Das Ganze in Staatsunternehmen war dann auch noch zusätzlich über Steuergelder finanziert worden. Und jetzt auf einmal mir gesagt wird, ja das kostet ja alles Geld, wo soll denn das herkommen? Ja ich muss ja auch mal sagen, ob die Telekom AG...
Also zum Beispiel der Kollege, der da bei mir montiert hat, die haben da auch zigtausende Leute entlassen, wie alle anderen. Ich würde einfach mal sagen, das ist einfach auch ein Prinzip der freien Marktwirtschaft, einfach, dass irgendwann mal die Gewinne springen und irgendwann geht alles runter.
Wenn es tatsächlich eine Marktwirtschaft wäre, dann hätte die Telekom kein Quasimonopol. Und das hat sie. Und selbst da, wo sie ihre Leitungen zur Verfügung stellen muss, müssen diejenigen, die ihr die Leitungen benutzen, ziemlich viel Geld bezahlen. Sodass auch keine wirkliche Marktwirtschaft entsteht.
Ja, aber ich schätze aber mal das Problem, dass sie zum Beispiel hier kein DSR legen, ist einfach, dass sie ziemlich in die roten Zahlen langsam kommen.
Da hab ich mal eine ganz andere Legende gehört, und zwar, dass deren ganze Opal-Technik von Alcatel kommt und die mit Alcatel nicht mehr arbeiten wollen.
Nein, nein, ich meine aber jetzt die Sache.
Wer hat mir auch erzählt, zum Beispiel, dass die Entwicklung und die Kostenvermittlungsstellen flächendeckend über Glasfaser zu entwickeln und diese ganze Modentechnik und so weiter, das würde im Moment, also den Etat, das können locker mal ein paar Hundert Millionen sein, den haben sie nicht mehr, nicht auf Verdacht, wenn sie nicht abschätzen können, wie viele Leute das kaufen. Das glaube ich immer auch.
Das ist durchaus nachvollziehbar, dass die Geldverkaufung da ist.
Wir sind gerade in der Flaute, das glaube ich schon auch mal. Und was das Glasfaser betrifft, ich sag einfach mal, als die Glasfaser hier eingebaut wurde, da war das wirklich das Modernste, was am Markt war. Glasfaserkabel sind sehr teuer. Das war auch ein Gedanke der Wirtschaftsförderung, weil das auch nicht jeder herstellen kann auf der Welt. Das ist nämlich auch deutsche Materialtechnik, sagen wir mal, so gewesen. Aber die Planung für Glasfaser flächendeckend irgendwann mal zu entwickeln, was wir da nicht gemacht haben, vielleicht aus Kostengründen oder sonst was, die kommt ja noch aus dem Kalten Krieg. Weil das wäre die Fortschreibung des Internetprinzips, weil Glasfaser nämlich einfach in dem Falle, selbst im Atomkriegsfalle, eine relativ viel sicherere Kommunikation gewährleistet. Ist so. Ist galvanisch getrennt. Und als sie dann entwickelt wurde, hatten wir noch den Kalten Krieg. Als sie dann fertig war und marktbereit, da ging der Osten auf. Der Osten hat geschrien, wir wollen alle Telefonnummern. So, jetzt verkaufen wir unsere Glasfaser. Jetzt haben wir unsere Unternehmen, die die produzieren. Und dann haben wir das schnellste Netz der Welt. Und dass wir dann später darauf kommen, dass man fünf Jahre vorher DSL weiterentwickeln könnte. Das ist aber wieder eine Vermischung zwischen politisch-meditärischen Denken und monopol- oder komplex-Denken. Oder was weiß ich. Und dann kam halt der Hype. Und jetzt stehen sie halt da und die Kassen sind relativ leer. So würde ich das mal sehen.
Vielen Dank, Uwe. Und gute Nacht.
Ja, euch auch.
Also, ich habe mir ein DSL. Was? Was? Was? Was ist das denn? Ja, das verstehe ich nicht. Entschuldigt bitte, geneigte Hörende. Die Maschine macht nicht das, was wir wollen, was sie machen. Also das war jetzt quasi, was wir Fachleute nennen, ein Teaser. Ja, ein Teaser darauf, dass wir nach den Nachrichten und einer kleinen Musik tatsächlich zu Gehör bringen, was wir mit unserem Anwalt für ein Interview aufgezeichnet haben. Das ist komplett off-topic. Darum machen wir das nach den Nachrichten, damit es nicht heißt, wir hätten keine Brücke dahin gebaut, gekriegt, gefunden, getan, ge- Heute Nacht wenig Wolken. Tiefstemperaturen zwischen 13 und 9 Grad am Tag. Heiter und trocken die Höchstemperaturen dann 22 bis 26 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Boerner.
US-Präsident Bush hat die Europäische Union aufgefordert, ihren Widerstand gegen gentechnisch veränderte Lebensmittel aufzugeben. Auf einem Regierungstreffen sagte Bush, Genfot sei sicher und gesund. Die EU lehnt die Öffnung ihrer Märkte für Genlebensmittel ab. Bei diesem Thema gebe es verschiedene Meinungen, hieß es. Im Irak ist angeblich ein Bauteil für die Entwicklung von Atombomben gefunden worden. Der US-Nachrichtensender CNN berichtet, im Garten eines Privathauses sei eine Zentrifuge entdeckt worden, die aber bereits vor 12 Jahren versteckt wurde. Ein irakischer Wissenschaftler habe die Zentrifuge den US-Militärs übergeben. Bei den Tarifverhandlungen für die Druckindustrie gibt es eine Einigung. Die Beschäftigten erhalten in diesem Jahr 1, 5 Prozent und im nächsten Jahr 1, 7 Prozent mehr Geld. Das teilten die Gewerkschaft Verdi und der Verband der Druckindustrie mit. In der libräanischen Hauptstadt Manrovia hat es eine schwere Explosion auf dem Gelände der US-Botschaft gegeben. Dort sind offenbar mehrere Granaten eingeschlagen. Auf dem Gelände haben Tausende libräanische Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge Zuflucht gesucht. Es soll zahlreiche Verletzte gegeben haben. Genaue Zahlen sind uns bis jetzt immer noch nicht bekannt.
Unterverkehr auf Fritz, wir haben keine Meldungen, deswegen eine gute Fahrt. Wasch, eine Medienhure packt aus.
Ach so, so heißt sein Bühnenprogramm.
Schaut euch an, seht.
Und damit ist Tommy auf Tour in Berlin und Brandenburg.
Seht.
Für alle Termine, musste, musste klicken, klicken, unter www.fritz.de. Nochmal? Was? Kurzum? Tommy Wosch live on stage.
Ihr hört das Chaosradio Nummer 83 hier auf Fritz, Abenteuer, Letzte Meile, unser Thema. Und während also ein Bauteil für die Entwicklung von Atombomben gefunden wurde im Irak, haben wir ein Interview aufgezeichnet und zwar ein Interview mit Anwalt, wie heißt der noch gleich?
E-Punkt.
Anwalt E-Punkt. Das ist quasi auf Topic, weil wir uns ja eben so herrlich amüsiert haben über Telekom-Geschichten. Wir haben uns mal gefragt, beziehungsweise haben wir das den Anwalt gefragt, weil wir selber nicht wussten, wie ist es eigentlich mit Haftung und solchen Sachen?
Worüber wir vorhin eigentlich auch schon mal gesprochen hatten, was ist, wenn die Telekom irgendwie das Waveline bei dir offen installiert?
Genau das, also vom Anfang der Sendung. Die Antworten folgen jetzt. Also ich habe mir einen DSL-Zugang geholt. Ich habe die Telekom darum gebeten, mir doch ein W-Lan da hinzustellen. Das hat die Telekom auch gemacht. Ich habe mir das Handbuch nicht durchgelesen, weil kein Mensch im 21. Jahrhundert noch Handbücher durchlesen will. Und mein Netzwerk ist unsicher. Wer haftet dafür, wenn jemand anderes in meinem Namen E-Mails verschickt und Leute beleidigt beispielsweise?
Gut, die Haftung für die E-Mails, die da verschickt werden, die richtet sich in der Linie danach, von welchem Account die aus gesendet worden sind. Das ist der erste Ansprechpunkt. Das heißt, der erste Ansprechpartner in dem Fall wirst immer du sein, auch wenn du diese E-Mail gar nicht verfasst hast. Das wird ermöglicht dadurch, dass das W-Lan offen war. Und da ist dann die große Frage, ob du davon hast Kenntnis haben können oder nicht. Grundsätzlich so, wenn das in einem Handbuch steht, dass man dem durchschnittlichen User trotz allem noch zumutet, ist das Handbuch dann auch zu lesen dazu. In den Fällen der Telekom jetzt allerdings ist es da ein bisschen anders, weil ja da meistens installiert wird von Seiten der Firma. Wenn da kein Inweis erfolgt von den Personen, die das Gerät zu Hause installieren, also von den Installationen zu Beamten, oder wie auch immer man sie nennen will, dann kann das nicht zugemutet werden, dass man dann von sich aus auf den Gedanken kommt und in diesen Handbuch nachschaut.
Ja, aber wie weiß ich nach, dass die mir nicht gesagt haben, dass ich nochmal ins Handbuch gucken muss wegen der Sicherheit?
Ja, das ist wie gesagt eine Beweisfrage dann auch hinsichtlich des Gesprächs oder hinsichtlich der Aktion, aus der von der Telekom beauftragte das Gerät installiert hat, dass diesen Inhalt des Gesprächs oder den Inhalt dieser Aktion, den muss man unter Beweis stellen können.
Gibt es da denn irgendwelche Beispielfälle schon, also irgendwelche Urteile, die da gefällt wurden? Weil letztendlich ist es ja auch möglich, dass jemand Geld ausgibt unter Verwendung meines Accounts. Also T-Online bietet sowas ja an. Wer zahlt das dann?
Fälle sind mir bisher noch nicht bekannt. Das mag auch daran liegen, dass es da meistens ja dann doch um kleinere Beträge geht. Also kleinere, aber jedenfalls nicht unbedingt solche, die dann bis zum BGH reichen, wo man ja eine gewisse Summe erst mal erreichen muss, um den ganzen Instanzen zu gehen zu können. Wie gesagt, wenn diese Aufklärung, und ich meine, dass es dann eine entsprechende Aufklärungspflicht der Telekom dann auch gibt, wenn das nicht erfolgt, dann ist das eigentlich ein Produktschaden. Das heißt, ein mittelbarer Schaden, der entsteht aus dem von der Telekom vertriebenen Produkt, nämlich Wafler an den Verbindungen DSL. Damit haftet dann auch die Telekom für eintretende Schäden, die daraus entstehen, dass da jemand dann eben von diesem Account aus irgendwelche Rechtsgeschäfte abschließt, für die man in erster Linie mal gerade stehen muss. Und auch Wirt oder MCN-Sender und sogar über die Telekom-Rechnung das Ganze abgerechnet wird.
Muss die Telekom nachweisen, dass sie mich beraten hat, indem ich eine Unterschrift leiste?
Das wäre ganz gut, wenn sie das tun würde, wenn sie jemanden diese Unterschrift abbringen würde. Das wäre für ihre Position sicherlich gut. Aber die Beweislast für diese Sachen, die liegt zum einen erstmal vom User. Es gibt einen Grundsatz, dass man all das beweisen muss, was einem günstig ist. Und in dem Fall muss man eben beweisen, dass die Aufklärung unterblieben ist. Das geht aber da in erster Linie jetzt mal um die Aufklärung durch denjenigen, der das Welschland zu Hause installiert hat. Also wenn diese Personen dann mich aufklären, dann, wie gesagt, ist es kaum zumutbar, dass man von sich aus auf die Idee kommt, jetzt schau ich mal ins Handbuch, ob mir der nicht etwas Wichtiges verschwiegen hat.
Bleiben wir bei der Telekom und dem Datenschutz. Ich persönlich stehe nicht im Telefonbuch, damit niemand an meine Adresse kommt. Wer jetzt allerdings meine Telefonnummer, also meine Zuhause-Telefonnummer hat, der muss nur bei der Störungsstelle anrufen. Und dann sagt der freundliche Herr oder die freundliche Dame an der Störungsstelle, ah, Holger Klein. Und möglicherweise sagt er dann auch noch meine Adresse. Dürfen die sowas überhaupt? Und warum machen die das dann?
Ja, ich nehme an aus Allmachtsgedanken, oder aus jedem versehenden Bewusstsein für die Sensibilität von solchen Daten.
Was darf ich mit denen anfangen, wenn die sowas machen, obwohl sie es nicht dürfen?
Ja, das ist ein großes Problem, weil der Schaden ist, also im deutschen Recht ist es so, dass immaterielles Schaden nur in Einzelfällen, in solchen, die vom Gesetz bestimmt werden, bezahlt wird. Das ist das berühmte Schmerzwert bei Unfällen etwa. Das ist ja zum Ausgleich von immateriellen Schaden, also nicht von den Krankenhausaufnahmskosten etc. oder Verdienstasser, sondern das sind materielle Schäden, sondern eben die psychischen Leiden oder die Leiden allgemein sollen damit ausgeglichen werden. Leider gibt es sowas im Datenschutzrecht noch nicht. Also es gibt kein Schmerzengeld für Verstöße gegen Geld im Datenschutzrecht oder Verstöße eben allgemein gegen privacy Grundsätze. Wenn aus dieser Preiskabel der Daten dann tatsächlicher Schaden entsteht, sprich der Eintrecher weiß ja dann, wo er ranklopfen darf, dann kann er ja die restlichen Daten auch noch erfahren, mutmaßlich, dann könnte man tatsächlich da ein Präzedenzvermahlung durchziehen. Ich denke auch nicht sehr gut in Aussichten, weil das ist ein glatter Verstoß. Jedenfalls dann, wenn man es widersprochen hat, dem Eintrag im Telefonbuch. Ansonsten handelt es sich um einen Ausgangsschloss im öffentlichen Register, die insoweit nicht straftbewehrt ist. Das ist also auch kein Verstoß mit der Telekom bestehenden Vertrag.
Wäre das denn dann nicht sinnvoll, wenn wir die Telekom dazu bewegen, eine Passwort-Abfrage davor zu schalten, so wie zum Beispiel, wenn ich bei meinem Handyprovider anrufe, ohne Passwort geben die überhaupt keine Daten raus?
Ja, das wäre ja eine probate Gegenmaßnahme dazu. Das sollte man tatsächlich mal anregen. Man hat allerdings auf sowas erst keinen Rechtsanspruch. Der Verstoß gegen das Datenschutzrecht ist allerdings so massiv in diesem Fall, dass man wegen könnte, da über den Datenschutzbeauftragten der Länder oder auch dem Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten eine entsprechende Anfrage zu stellen.
Tja, und genau das werden wir doch machen, wenn wir das nächste Mal begrüßt werden mit Namen, Adresse und Sozialversicherungsnummern. Chaosradio Nr. 83 auf Fritz ist es, was ihr hört. Zehn Minuten Zeit haben wir noch, dann geht's ja weiter mit dem Night Flight. Und in diesen zehn Minuten würden wir ganz gerne noch das eine oder andere Abenteuer mit der Letzten Meile von euch hören unter 0331 70 97 110. Welche bizarren Erlebnisse habt ihr denn so mit der Deutschen Telekom gehabt? Da gibt es nämlich sehr viel. Was mich ja auch sehr erschüttert hat, die wollten mal kein Geld von mir. Das fand ich auch so alt. Ich bin umgezogen, neuen Anschluss angemeldet, kriegte dann einen Brief, ja bla, da ist noch 1, 49 Euro offen, auf eine Erhebung der Forderung verzichten wir mit freundlichen Grüßen Ihre Deutsche Telekom. Das ist entsetzlich, oder? Nicht?
Das ist dann völlig den Wind aus den Segel.
Und dann gab es irgendwie, das ist ewig her, das muss Mitte der 90er gewesen sein, es war damals auch im Web dokumentiert, da gab es tatsächlich offensichtlich ein Mahnschreiben, wo der Kunde der Telekom letztmalig aufgefordert wurde, bei Androhung den Anschluss abzuklemmen, jetzt endlich die offene Rechnung in Höhe von DM 0 zu bezahlen. Das gab es irgendwo im Web. Ich denke mal, wer lang genug sucht, der findet dieses Schreiben auch noch.
Hiermit überweise ich Ihnen sofort wirkend den Betrag von 0.
Ja, aber was machst du denn da? Ich überweise es am besten irgendwie einen, damit du einen Guthaben hast.
Oh, wenn du ihn also einen Cent überweist, dann werden sie wahrscheinlich total panisch da drüben, weil sie nicht wissen, wie sie es abrechnen sollen.
Glaubst du, das sind solche Buchhalter? Ich meine, wenn die das immer gemessen daran, dass die Rechnungen praktisch nie stimmen, oder zumindest seltenst stimmen, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so ein nervöser Buchhalter ist.
Aber die stellen sich ja da selber ja die Rechnungen.
Guten Abend, Falko. Eine lange Story. Eine lange Story, genau. Dann fangen wir mal an.
Also ich hab angefangen, also ich war mal in den USA, wie man das so mal macht, und hab da über DSL gelesen. Fand das super toll, war wieder in Deutschland, ruft bei der Telekom an und dachte, also wenn es in Amerika geht, muss es ja auch in Deutschland gehen.
Ist so, erster Satz, was ist DSL?
Wann war das?
Es war vor über fünf Jahren. So, ich so, na ja, okay, haben sie noch nicht, werden sie vielleicht bald rausbringen. Sie haben wirklich auch ein halbes Jahr später dann angefangen, DSL ein bisschen besser anzupreisen. So in internen Kreisen, so Anfragen, wer das haben möchte. Hab ich natürlich gleich E-Mail geschrieben und alles gemacht, als ich das haben möchte. Das Problem ist bloß, ich komme aus der Opalwüste Marzahn. Also, gut gefragt und alles gemacht. Aber, Opal geht halt nicht. Nun hab ich vor über zwei Jahren meine Lehre als Fachinformatiker angefangen. Und zwar beim Blauen Riesen. Wenn dir das was sagt. Hab nun halt auch dadurch, dass ich im Rechenzentrum der Telekom ein bisschen rumgeturnt bin.
Mir sagt das ja nix, ne?
Wie?
Der Blaue Riese. Mir sagt das, was ist das?
Diese Firma von denen hier, die drei Notebooks zum Beispiel.
Ja! Ach so!
Ja, da gibt's noch welche von...
Das war keine Schleichung, aber wenn ihr Blauer Riese habt, müsst ihr mir auch sagen, was das heißt. Ich bin doof.
Kein Waschmittel. Und hab halt im Rechenzentrum von der Telekom auch ein bisschen rumgesprungen. Und hab mich halt noch ein bisschen intensiver mit DSL befasst. Interessant war, DSL wurde hier überall abgelehnt an sich. Bloß hab dann festgestellt, dass drei Straßen weiter halt wieder funktioniert. War ich etwas verdutzt?
Ja, ist ja durchaus möglich.
Okay, an sich brauch ich kein DSL.
Es ist auch durchaus möglich, vom Blitz erschlagen zu werden.
Ja, sozusagen. Eigentlich hätte mir eine ISDN-Flatrate gereicht. Weil zum Online-Spielen reicht auch ISDN. Und saugen und machen und tun, das kostet nur Traffic. Und es tut der Wirtschaft auch nicht gut. Also, lassen wir's.
Welcher Wirtschaft?
Das ist kollegial.
Das ist die Wirtschaft, um die ich abends um ein Bier trinke?
Die eigentlich der Telekommunikationswirtschaft.
Ah ja, die. Sind das die, die durch zu hoch bewerteten Immobilien besitzt, Kleinanleger um ihr...
Wenn du kein Traffic machst.
Das ist ja auch dieser Punkt, dass sich die größten europäischen Telekommunikationsgesellschaften jetzt im Sommer getroffen haben oder kurz vor dem Sommer, also Anfang des Sommers so rum, und haben wohl festgelegt, dass sie in den nächsten zwei Jahren nur noch Traffic, also volumenbegrenzte Flatrates anbieten.
Dabei haben sie dicke Glasfaserleitungen rum, liegen sie hier rumgammeln.
Wie bitte?
Dabei haben sie echt viele dicke Glasfaserbackbones, wo irgendwie nur der Traffic nur durchtropfelt, wo sie viel Geld reingesteckt haben.
Was ich dann zu dem einen Herrn, der nicht bei der Telekom arbeitet und vor uns angerufen hat, sagen wollte, natürlich will kein anderer Glasfaser haben, wenn die Telekom nur für DSL-Werbung macht. Also, sagen wir doch mal ehrlich, die meisten Leute, die hier normal zu Hause sitzen, haben keine Ahnung von der Telekom und was da alles geht und was da nicht geht. Und so ist das ja auch kein Problem. Sie haben halt andere Fachgebiete. Aber wenn mir jemand eine Glasfaserleitung geben würde, würde ich die sofort kaufen, wenn sie nur ein jahrmaßen Geldbetrag liegt, wo man sich das noch leisten kann.
Ja und selbst wenn sie nur so bunte Farben macht, wie diese Glasfaser-Streuze.
Hauptsache Glasfaser.
Ja, Glasfaser und dann aufgesplittet auf die Spektalfarben kriegt man schöne Leitungen durch. Liefer waren es ein paar 1000 Gigabit oder so. Da gibt es irgendwie ein Versuchsprojekt gerade. Aber egal. Interessant ist halt nur, dass es eigentlich nur ein kleiner Wandler ist, den sie einbauen müssen. Den sie wohl auch angeblich jetzt hier anfangen, in den Häusern einzubauen. Also hier in Marzahn jetzt einbauen, um das zu machen.
Ja, das tun sie in Hohenschenhausen auch.
Weil komischerweise, vor einem halben Jahr funktioniert die DSL eine Straße weiter noch nicht. Jetzt funktioniert es. Aber ihr Problem? Ratet mal die Ports. Dieses, was sie immer sagen, Ports haben wir nicht frei, können wir nicht liefern, bla, und diese Standardausrede. Was halt eigentlich auch noch interessant ist, wieso darf man bei UPAL nicht auf einen anderen Anbieter wechseln? Technisch müsste es möglich sein.
Akor sagt ja auch, dass das geht.
Bei denen geht alles.
Und Telekom und T-Online sind zwei unterschiedliche Unternehmen.
Also, um auf einen anderen Anbieter zu wechseln, müsste der Anbieter Technik in die Vermittlungsstelle stellen und die anderen Anbieter haben keine Anschlusstechnik mehr dafür.
Also, keiner will sich das ans Bein binden und es gibt halt auch keine Technik mehr neu zu kaufen und so weiter.
Das ist aber eigentlich schade, weil besonders in den UPAL-Wüsten sehr große Anfrage nach DSL ist.
Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, eigentlich will man ja auch gar keinen DSL unbedingt haben. Man möchte halt einfach Internet haben. Und da liegt halt schon Glasfaser und da könnte man so toll schnell das Internet drüber machen.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber weil das halt nicht ins Marketing-Konzept der Telekom passt, wird das dann halt nicht getan.
Genau. Und was auch sehr interessant ist, das Gerücht, dass jedes Internetcafé eine Standleitung hat. Ich kenne ein paar Internetcafés und ich kenne keins davon, was sich eine Standleitung leisten kann. 1.500 Euro für eine Internetleitung im Monat auszugeben. Na, Standleitung, es sind ja 20 ISDN-Kanäle zusammen.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Standleitungen.
Das kommt ja immer drauf an. Also was du jetzt meinst, ist ein S2M. Also was als Telefon, was halt auch in Firmen liegt, das sind halt 30 ISDN-Kanäle. Oder halt, wenn man das als reine Datenleitung benutzt, dann 2 MBit, die da drüber gehen. Und das gibt es halt zu kaufen, ist halt, wie du sagtest, ziemlich teuer, kostet irgendwie. Also es gibt es schon für, ich glaube, so um die 3.000 Euro.
Die Leitung selber ist ziemlich billig.
Na, es geht 300 Euro im Monat oder so.
330 Euro und dann kommt aber halt noch das IP dazu. Und da brauchst du einen Provider, der ein gutes Angebot macht.
Und da ist es dann halt deutlich billiger, einfach DSL zu nehmen, weil das wird auch in Business-Varianten angeboten. Und wo du halt beliebig viele Rechner dran hängen kannst. Und hat zwar auch oft dann so die Beschränkung, dass es halt zu dir, also der Download zu dir, schneller geht als in die andere Richtung. Aber zum Klicken im Internetcafé reicht das ja vollkommen.
Zum größten Teil, aber es ist ja an sich keine wirkliche Standleitung, wenn man das so sieht. Es ist eine DSL-Leitung, aber...
Naja, das ist der letzte...
Das kommt darauf an, wie man eine Standleitung definiert.
Das ist eine Definitionsfrage.
Ich unterbreche euch ja ungern, Jungs. Aber die Sendung ist zu Ende, die sogenannte. Falko, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Und gute Nacht. Und Matthias und Florian, nichts für ungut. Wir haben leider keine Zeit mehr. Es geht nämlich auf eine Uhr weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Das war das Chaosradio Nr. 83, Abenteuer Letzte Meile. Wir haben versucht zu erkunden und zu ergründen. Das nächste Chaosradio wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt am 30. Juli. Und danach ist ja dann schon August und da ist dann Camp.
Genau, 7. bis 10. August ist das Camp.
Wo wir uns hoffentlich sehen. www.cccde.com Da steht alles.
Was kostet denn eigentlich? Ist das wieder so ein Pressevertreter, der aus Versehen seinen Presseausweis dabei hat, muss 1000 Mark zahlen?
Das steht auf der Seite, das könnt ihr selber klicken.
Du hast es dir nicht durchgelesen.
Doch, doch, das hab ich, aber ich will nichts Falsches verkünden und dann in die Diskussion jetzt auch nicht einsteigen.
Alles klar, im Studi waren Tobias Thorsten und Krüggs. Krüggs. Krüggs. Wie schreibt man das eigentlich? Ah ja, und Krüggs. Die Knöpfe gerückt hat Holger Klein. Wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns morgen Abend wieder, da steh ich schon wieder hier. Wenn ihr nicht wollt, dann schaltet eben nicht ein. Vielen Dank und bitte Robert.